fortnite he is a complete boss um
uh he's he's he's a total boss but i i
feel like since he's already playing
this like king's indian setup
i like it a lot for him because it feels
like he's very good with the bishops and
this kings in the attack kings indian
setup
um where you bring out your bishops
makes a lot of sense and i also pointed
out
um before uh zextrow it feels like
he's got that nate hill sort of gene in
him where he um
where he can sort of coordinate the
pieces the bishops especially
and i was going to add i forgot to
mention this earlier the other guy who
was very good at using bishops
it occurred to me was uh with scissors
and i don't maybe it's because they're
fortnite guys
but all three of them they it feels like
they've got that they've got that like
that ability to understand and use the
bishops better than most of the other
players that doesn't mean they're better
players because you have to use all your
forces all the pieces on the board
but it seems like he knows what he's
doing quite well so
i'm i'm really looking forward to it i
think zextro is a big favorite to um
to win today i think he's doing well um
so yeah i'm really looking forward to it
um
i guess zextra is playing a game right
now so i think i'm gonna watch like a
couple of games with zach
sorrow let me um well let me let me
watch him tsm
okay i'm gonna watch a couple of games
let's let's watch some games
um i'm just gonna watch a few games a
few games
right now so all right this game should
be starting it
is game aborted exciting game aboard so
i guess it's going to queue up again
um let's go again okay so let's watch
this game
sd 1427 against tsm zextra i'm gonna
watch two games
oh he wants white okay well he's still
doing fine okay so he's gonna play the
night out
playing the pyrrhic defense very good so
far he'll probably play g6
let's see probably g6 here very good
very very good i like it i really do
like i like the way that it's just basic
it's a basic setup very straightforward
pyrrhic i would not recommend in general
but if he if he's good with the bishop
he understands what he's doing
then um then yeah i like it
so okay so probably castles good very
good
i'm very happy with this i'm not gonna
lie i'm very very happy with this
okay so now when he if he even remembers
if he puts two and two together he
should play knight d7
okay yeah what can i say what can i say
this is exactly what i want to see
this is exactly what i want to see you
guys as far as far as the stuff
going forward in november um i don't
think it's going to be an issue i've had
some discussions with um
with chess 24 already regarding the
event so i don't expect it to be an
issue
um i think at the end of the day
everyone's going to be very reasonable
about what the reality is
okay so is he going to play e5 or c6 or
rookie 8 yeah
exactly this is good very good it's
exactly what i wanted to see
fantastic
okay and now as you're gonna follow the
plan just play e5
let's go okay see he plays knight f8
um okay should have played e5 first this
this slightly concerns me but i don't
think it's gonna matter for today
because i think he's just so much better
than his opponent than his opponent
um but i i like it i do like it in
general it's very good
um okay
now this is also where i want to see
like because he's obviously outside the
preparation though that's completely
different okay he plays e5 completely
fine
it doesn't matter like if the moves
aren't precise
that doesn't matter i just want to see
that he plays it with a concept
and a general general idea in mind as
opposed to just randomly making moves
and he's totally doing that here so it's
very very good
i like it i like it this is fantastic
this is very very very good and actually
d5 is not a great
move here i want to see if he plays h6
or h5 or knight h7 but in general i like
i like his
now he's gonna have to play a different
idea though so i want to see what he
comes up with here
why am i not in the olympiad i was busy
playing the magnus tournament i'm busy
streaming
um i i felt you know i felt there was
too many things going on besides this
that i just really didn't have time for
um so so yeah yeah there's two too many
other things going on
um all right so let's see
what does tsm stands for that's tsm
stands for team solomid
their origins are from league of legends
so that's that's that's
that's the that's the reason or not
reason sorry that that's that the
origins come from league and tsm stands
for team solomid
so okay okay plays h5 completely fine to
bring the knight out i mean
i think in general what he's doing is is
very uh is very logical
will i ever do a scientific card shirt
giveaway maybe a certain sub goal
again you guys we're we're so early in
this like it's we're just getting this
off the ground right now so um
so so yeah we'll um uh we'll we'll
figure it out but it's it we're we're
not at that we're not we're not
at that point yet um right right now
it's just getting the announcement out
there getting everything off the ground
and then
and then then taking from there but we
all all i mean i'm sure i'm sure i'll
have these discussions soon enough
thoughts on jeff bezos being worth 200
billion dollars what can i say
um it's it's crazy so let's see okay
that's fine
reasonable
okay this is all all pretty standard on
so let's see let's see what happens i'm
gonna play some music as well
will i wear a tsm jersey at tournaments
online over the board whatever it is of
course i will
obviously what i mean why would i not
wear them that would that would be
like i mean yeah if i if i'm signing
with an orgy guys i'm not doing it
just randomly or just because i want
money i'm doing excited like i like what
they're doing i like the org like
i mean it's kind of like i'll give you
an example when i was with red bull
a lot of people thought well you know
you're just you're just chilling red
bull um
but you know the the amount of the like
i always tried my best to like rep red
bull when i was with them
um and so yeah that's like that's kind
of what i'm saying it's
of course i will obviously
tsm jack would be great yeah
i honestly think you'd be a fantastic
valor cast commentator your voice is
good for
it yeah maybe i mean i don't really
get the game that well but yeah i mean
so yeah
i have a good voice for commentating
i've got the good voice for radio yeah
each pump blocked now and now you
develop bring everything else out
i've got the face for the radio 2 cap i
knew that was coming
i'm not with red bull anymore no i'm not
um i'm not
you know it's funny you said things for
radio and voice for print when i when i
said that
um when i said that briefly uh about tim
everyone was just like roasting me to no
end but like i say
there's no music you guys can hear the
music
no you can't wait what
oh you oh sorry
something i don't know my obs keeps
changing the uh output sorry
sorry why does it keep changing it keeps
changing the output i had that with
zextra for some reason
okay
um anyway yeah sorry you guys all right
would i wear a tsm jersey for otb
tournaments of course i would you guys
like i mean
i'm repping tsm like guys are crazy
would i wear a tsm jersey every day
forever now that is a different story i
don't know
i don't i don't know about that are
there no dress codes otv
acceptance are made in regards to dress
codes for sure
you know i'm not sure this guy's 600
they're playing a little bit a little
bit strangely
let me stop the music for one second um
what i'm gonna say as well you guys it's
like there are exceptions made for chess
terms so when
you know you have to understand there
are issues at times between chess
players organizers
and and everybody but people are
generally pretty reasonable in regards
to these sorts of things
so um i see no issues going forward
okay i'm just gonna watch this one game
let's see
you mean like allowing a player to
advertise a poker site while playing a
tournament yeah i mean i
again you guys i think at the end of the
day you know chess
we're always lacking in sponsors we're
lacking in visibility
and this is it's very important like
this is the thing like i think
i think organizers even understand this
that like it's very important like
you want more response you want more
interest and um
and so yeah i think going forward i
think you're gonna see more you're gonna
see more of this
and i i think it's a good thing
i think zextray's down tonight here but
his opponent is slow as molasses here so
he's probably gonna win the game on time
yeah so okay his opponent is uh way
too slow
way too slow that's one thing i've
noticed with zextra is he's very fast in
general as well
um thank you to uh tinsel kate for the
300 bit thank you duck shine for the
tier one they have sergeant floyd for
the two months they get a
i was magic as well so zeker's on fire
thank you vlogs for prime
xk40 for the two months dmd one zero one
zero one one with the prime
need g dip for the three months i don't
share with the prime that's 333
milliplay for the um
prime think of j core for the four
months say thank you to shibasaurus for
the prime thing
ironbar 200 for the prime the real mr
willis for the prime theater rep t4
rr for the tier one thing in motion with
the prime mini dd rake for the prime
thing ahmad likes chess for the 11
months
they had a 96 wait for the tier two they
needed a trim bought for the tier one
thank you to oklahos 11 for the 35th and
they need a good goal
for the 600 thank you chest today with
the prime adam maria for the two months
thank you to brozzo 1010 for the prime
minister solace for the two months
stated kagoma 310 for the prime and oh
micron for the win with the prime needed
what sour vector
for the prime they are all tourists for
the two months fish cake lover for the
tier one
you know psychedelic trampoline for the
tier one being a mastermind md for the
prime sword 462 with the prime
who boston for the five dollars i think
it flew for the prime they shade off for
the 15 months later bowie bowie 31 for
the three months
um thank you so much you guys appreciate
it thank you
see you tara twilight for the prime as
well okay let's see sex are playing same
opening
okay pretty good um he forgot to bring
the night out but it's
it's still i like the fact he's
following the principles and i don't
think this is gonna happen
um happen in his games today
he forgot the knight yeah but again he's
remembering the basic concept that's
what i want to see more than the result
tell the truth you're a new tsm jungler
i doubt but see even if this is not the
best move he still sees the clear threat
and he finds a way to block it so i like
it
that was a free queen oh wait actually
you guys i just realized i have to do
commentary in like
five minutes um oh i
actually i gotta do a commentary right
away i forgot sorry you guys i have to
do commentary right away
um for for pog champs so all right you
guys
uh zextrow wins again he's he's on fire
he's two out of two so
all right i'm gonna have to i'm gonna
have to call it because i have to go do
commentary i forgot
um before we go you guys uh just a
couple of things first of all thank you
so much to the mods for all they do all
they continue to do thank you so much
thank you for all the results and new
subs
thank you to all the fans honestly it's
been an amazing ride i'm really looking
forward to the future doing stuff with
tsm
um and just continuing continuing with
pog champs trying to raise the profile
of chess
obviously as i mentioned they're going
to be a lot of online chess tournaments
chess is certainly going to become an
esport and um
at the end of the day it's just it's
incredible to see i'm really really
grateful i never could have thought that
it would it would turn into this so um
thank you so much and um i i'm doing the
pod or i'm doing pog champs commentary
in a few minutes but
again just we keep it going and thank
you so much none of this would have been
possible without you guys uh the fans so
thank you i will see you guys either
later tonight or tomorrow hope you
enjoyed the stream and um
and really just love thank you guys
appreciate it send me a read the lobby
see you guys later
another trick isn't that like the third
one he's played at those he's played a
lot of them
played three of them goodness gracious
okay let's go leona i can't get out the
uh
i can't get out the acehole next turn so
warning stones isn't that great
i'm probably gonna go with solari
priestess that way i can play a six drop
next turn
like if i find sisters it's just so
strong
sure
bask and the lights radius oh i can't
play here yeah it's not day break
i forgot um maybe i just go with stones
on
i might die to these flyers i'm kind of
scared i guess stones is fun
i forgot it's not daybreak anymore
okay now i can do it
i got sisters nice i think it's sisters
right yeah it's sisters because it gives
me a flyer
and then next one i can go with this and
then a soul to turn after
we'll be chilling
i have not seen a thrush in forever
okay
not seen a threshing forever
am i attacking here or not i don't think
so
i don't think so
i could attack up the flyer i could
attack with the flyer
i missed four damage my bad sorry i was
thinking
nothing else it's fine i'm gonna jam
asol here
i think what do you do what the
it's fine i can block you i could
actually kill it with the six drop
i would rather play acell now though i'm
not gonna die am i no there's no chance
i die
obliterate two enemies is really good
but it's not a big deal it's not like
we're gonna die here so i'm not terribly
concerned
like this yeah
imagine overwhelm jeez
okay so we actually have a aurelian
souls to send the sky
soon um
actually do we even have it next turn
no we don't
spooky
okay charger all right
it's not a great card but it's fine
okay how do i win this game
i guess i can supernova but it's a
little slow
um
aurelian needs to upgrade though that's
the problem
oh i can play the board wipe after this
actually
that's pretty broken
it gives me mana yeah
oh i lost to this i lost it
oh no oh my gosh
oh my goodness
okay all right let's go
uh what's the worst deck on this
or what silver's card on this harsh wins
was okay
hush is okay honestly behold's kind of
bad
all right i think i have time for about
one more game
so for those of you who don't know uh
there is some prime loot
for this game so all you have to do is
connect your twitch account
or your prime account to your twitch
account uh click on the link
at the bottom or uh i think there's a
command in chat
and then you can claim your loot for lor
it gives you a
legendary wild card and all that stuff
so just
a lot of benefits with prime
i'm waiting for the boys personally
that's gonna be fun
don't have time you're already on stream
all right this might be my last one
all right uh two into three into four
we have five minute after it's a very
similar duck so it'll be all right
it seems like a bad matchup they're
gonna beat out if leon isn't fast enough
um honestly the ramp is about the same
and i don't think trundle is that big of
a deal uh because you get
leo now to turn earlier and it's kind of
hard for him to deal with leona
because uh the vulnerable card comes out
too late
hello jealous people yes hello
attacking does nothing but i like seeing
them hit each other so it's all good
it's a mirror match pretty much he
doesn't run leona though and he's
running that card that's interesting
okay ava's okay let's go and play leona
i could i could ramp more but there's
nothing to ramp to so leona is fun
i'll give tft a try when it comes out um
yeah i'll give it a chance
it's pretty fun i like it it's good kim
splendor reveals
avalanche sure that's nothing i wonder
if i even played that it doesn't
actually help him
i guess it saves them like three health
how do you know it's day break daybreak
is the first card um you playing around
says it over
okay let's see here
i want a ramp but the problem is there's
nothing to ramp into this i was talking
about
it's like uh
of interesting
actually this might give me enough
damage just to kill him give allies two
to this round shuffle leon in your duck
let's go two five
two one five maybe
two one five is fine into five cut the
other
oh trickster or charger maybe charger a
lot damage
okay maybe i don't ram maybe i'll just
play the one and then next turn we pop
off
no no no we should ramp
okay next time we go one five
i kind of get blown out by a second
avalanche but we just have to hope he
doesn't have it
gosh that card's so good
okay um is this set up lethal two two
two
similar damage i'm just gonna develop
the five drop so don't get blown out
poggers
species sketchy
that thing is big i'm scared of that
thing
has overwhelm also i'm a little spooked
i can stun it though but it's a spell
shield right
we will not suffer unbelievers doesn't
actually get stuns behold the sun's holy
light
all right i have to attack him with some
things probably these
you can get a trade but it's fine i'm
just scared of irelian coming out
that's soon
i don't need to play that it's fun
okay
daybreak activate all allied daybreaks
effects at once
part's a little scary i can just kill it
i think
it's probably scarier than this question
mark probably
i don't know is this thing even scary
whatever i'll just kill it
this thing might be scarier it's hard to
say
if you're ahead you should trade
[Music]
so
trainer cocoona
trainer again and venusaur
wait we're in the game we're in the game
oh [__] juice liquor
i don't know dude don't know what to do
mike is throbbing throbbing
did we deserve that game i think we did
did you
[Music]
of bad oh moist if you're watching make
sure you call me
boy boy the winner somebody
so i've been playing like 50 a day
that's you're just 2d auntie that's what
you are because no matter what you do
box box
i will destroy you oh no no
no no and it's too soon
it's too soon hikaru we didn't even
reach a climax
[Music]
[Applause]
so
i got my star in chess at the age of
seven years old i was really young
i assume in this position i'm white so
i'm down three pawns
or no i played played a lot became the
youngest master in america 10 years old
breaking records there the lineup was
talking about c5 knight c3 bishop v7 95
bishop d5 cd5
i've won the united states chess
championship five times which is third
most trying to win the pawn on d5 d6
cd ed rook d6 and then he had rook fb1
because of king of sixers 94.
then i broke bobby fischer's record the
firm former world champion to become
a grand master takes here here takes
here here
here and you just win the game and i'm
also number one ranked in the world
blitz chat so i'm just the best
oh ah that's right oh my god it's right
one thing i really want to do
is whomever i represent try to bring
home titles bring home trophies and i
feel that my best
opportunities to do that will be at tsm
it should be like this should be like
this should be like this
okay very nice there we go one two three
oh my god he actually might lose on time
who come on come on make it make me make
a move
hikaru nakamura professional chess
player grand master united states chess
champion i'm here to announce that i'm
signing with tsa
[Music]
and in case you missed it the biggest
news of this day will be
remembered not as pog champs but of
course that hikaru nakamura
announced that he has signed with tsm
hikaru
huge congratulations man i've now
watched the video a few times i've
enjoyed it so much i'm i'm just so happy
for you and
what can you say man yeah i mean i i
think uh
i mean obviously still sinking in uh
it's been it's been a long time coming i
think um
more than anything though it's great to
see all the fans who have been so
supportive over the past couple of
months
and really since since february when the
world kind of changed unfortunately and
so really just to see the support to
love from everybody
it means the world to me so i just
really want to say uh thank you so much
everyone but before we dive into
pogchamps i'm gonna just say that i
caught the end of your stream there and
you were talking about
just you know how big you feel this is
for chess in general right obviously you
know the success that you're having
right now and you deserve all of it and
you've worked so hard to
to get tsm and have this opportunity but
but talk a little bit if you would just
more about why why you think this is
important that someone like you
who's playing in the elite the most
elite of events and finals against
magnus carlsen
is bringing this type of attention to
the game and and what you
where you see it going from here not
asking for any secret plans with tsm or
anything or even if you know them but
but how big
do you feel this is for chess in general
even outside of your channel
yeah i mean i i think in general it's
great to see i think certainly with
chess it's becoming more and more of an
esport
as i mentioned on my own there are going
to be a lot of events online in the next
year
um for sure that that have been that
have been uh guaranteed so
um yeah i think it's it's just amazing
to see for chess it's great to see the
crossover
i think certainly when people think of
chess they don't necessarily think of an
esport but chess probably is the
original
i don't even know the original yeah
original game um
right i mean it's been it's been around
for so long obviously
but i feel in many ways with what's
happened it sort of pushed
us in the direction that i think we were
inevitably headed towards anyway with
more and more online events
and more and more rapid and blitz
tournaments so uh yeah it's just it's
great to see it honestly i know people
saying that it seems so serious um
more than anything is trying not to get
emotional about it because it's just
been
it's just been non-stop really uh since
since like february since march and just
to see all the support see all those all
the big streamers
you know the guys like xqc the guys like
forsen um who have really pushed it
forward um
it's just amazing and as i said earlier
uh not to not to be a little bit sad but
you know i in many ways i i would be
remiss if i did not really say that
for me personally it does it does it's a
little bit sad just the the byron is not
here because i feel in many ways a lot
of what has happened with me as a
streamer
a lot of sort of stuff um well it wasn't
the the main reason i got into it
um he certainly was someone that i
really did look up to and all the stuff
he did
and even though even when i look back um
a few months i felt like the
really the peak before we did pog champs
was again something that involved him it
was that match that he played against
xqc um yeah they put that six game match
at blitz so
i really wish he he he was here to see
that but nonetheless um
i think a lot of people along the way
have been been very helpful it's just
it's been amazing well said man and
he'll definitely
be remembered by many and and uh your
your success i'm sure
just something he probably thought was
coming and you deserve it and uh
how's that shirt feel oh it feels great
i mean the thing is i've actually had my
merch since since last weekend
um it's it's been very hard because well
you could work
you know it's like for example i have
this i have this bottle and i've had it
it's like i've actually been using it
but i have to be careful not to use that
be careful not to wear certain shirts um
so for the last like week it's been it's
been a little bit um it's been a little
bit uh a little bit strange but
certainly to have it out there now it's
incredible and um and really i'm just
very thankful to the fans i mean it is
the fans who have made all this possible
um i i i think somewhere in the back of
my mind i always thought chess had this
potential
but for someone who spent my ho for
someone who spent their whole life in
chess to see it actually realizing this
way
um after what i feel there's so many
blown opportunities to make the game go
bigger
it's uh just it's it's hard to put into
words
again man it's awesome and again for
those just tuning in hikara nakamura has
signed with tsm and there's the shirt
there's the mug
and and there's the uh there's the pog
chance format card let's remind
everybody of what they're
tuning in right tuning into um for those
who i saw asking in chat uh ludwig will
likely be joining us soon he's got he's
got a lot going on today so hikaru and i
are are
flying flying together here and ludwig
may be with us
very very soon but in front of you you
see the format remember
the uh the biggest chess event that it
has been for the last
few months the second edition of
pogchamps the only major change being
that it is a double round robin we've
been doing this for the last week they
get to play a game with each color
our our streamers the winners move on to
the uh today
is here actually oh there's the [__] up
what's up dude how's it going man hey
car how's it feel about the second
biggest announcement of the day
i knew you were gonna make something
full-time chess player
yeah yeah yeah sorry i was learning the
hand signal took me about three hours
uh some a little bit late but i think i
we
didn't even have time to make fun of you
or talk bad about you you promised me
you were gonna be late today man
yeah i guaranteed i'd be late well look
you know it's just because
hey i wanted to i wanted he car to have
his one moment before i make the rest of
the show about me
all right i'm being a nice guy
well again i did and we did we did have
a good moment you hear the news hicaro's
with tsm
and uh it's a big deal ludwig yeah
it is i thought it was super hype i
thought that that was that was sick you
are now
equals to like all esports legends
you're basically the ninja of chess
hey that he he is and uh don't steal my
line
um is that your line that was my yeah
actually yeah yeah ludwig just to give
you some backstory like when i first
like when i first sort of got into
streaming danny's sort of he that was
his thought he thought maybe one day i
could be like the ninja of chess oh
we were we were having dinner in the
aisle at the isle of man
hey kara was playing in an elite event
and we were having dinner at the isle of
man and i said dude
i think this could be it and uh and he
did it right he's done it
um what does that make you who's like
are you
are you jessica then are you like where
i will be hikaru's jessica blevins if
that's what he's into but i don't think
he would see me that way i i'm uh
i'm nobody i'm a i'm a dad who who makes
things awkward i i will say this
we have the groups we're still here to
have a show what'd you say then just
you're one of ninja's mods right you're
there
you guys mud you're like boss uh but
here we are it's it's
it's cutie right it's cutie pointer
cutie playing today
uh well she plays she plays later i
think it's dot it's dog hits
yeah blade first okay yeah yeah yeah dog
dog vs all right sure
um the games haven't even started yet so
don't worry fans you haven't missed
anything part of that was because dog
dog was busy um with a uh
apparently a major hearthstone event
today but he he says that uh he's here
now
we're about t minus two minutes away
guys from the game so
let's talk a little bit about the groups
or i guess the two mattresses we have we
have dog dog and tf blade and then we
have zex
row versus cutie so hey carl you gave a
lesson to sex
earlier today how'd that go how did this
feel seem for the game
um pretty good i i feel like there are a
couple people who it seems like their
feel is very good for having not played
a lot i think wagamam is the most
obvious example for someone who has not
played a lot but clearly is very strong
i thought zextra also he's able to put
two and two together that doesn't mean
he finds all the best moves but in terms
of basic plans
he seems pretty solid and stable so i i
do like his chances
um i i think he's probably a favorite in
that match against cutie probably
um the other match i really have no idea
to what what to make of i feel like
one thing maybe ludwig can speak to this
a little bit but i feel like with this
uh pog champs too there is certainly
more pressure it seems like on some of
the players than on
than in the the original one it feels
like people like dog because he is
training with hafu i mean
they're they're together obviously but
because they're like both competing
there's i think the sense that he's
really really strong
and it seems to me that some of these
guys uh they're the pressure perhaps is
a little bit too much so i wonder what
ludwig
i mean these matches are they're sweaty
right i feel like this is
this is way sweatier than the last one
where the last one
it was like you know slicker figured out
that the horse moves into l shape and
then everyone pog champ in chat
and now it's like you know pressure's on
i think i think it's
it's less of a new thing and more of a
chess tournament
right than last time yeah i wonder about
that too because we know that it's you
know that's maybe
led to some expectations or frustrations
at times because there is a lot of hype
there was a lot of buildup from the
first one and now
everyone really wants to do well so
hopefully as the as the event goes on
and and i think as we have also the
championship bracket and the consolation
bracket
all the matches will continue to get
even closer right i think i think in the
next round where the players are
maybe more evenly paired in both
brackets it's going to make it more
enjoyable all around and make the games
um super close for sure so all right
well there we go we have the players
dog dog is also streaming he is uh he's
at his twitch channel
i believe tf blade is also streaming i
think no he's not sorry he's with us on
zoom my bad
so tiaf blade is with us on zoom so stay
here everybody because guess what
we have liftoff here we go game started
all right what do we think about these
openings this is obviously oh this could
get there could be a trick here at the
very start
danny do you think that that uh tf oh
there's a trick
oh oh did he prepare this oh oh my gosh
oh this is so dirty car was a lot of
they asked me whether we thought dog dog
was setting the trick and indeed he
answers the question this is a common
trap
yeah this happened to me this happened
to me against uh i think papa plot he
did the similar thing where i just
i thought he made a stupid dumb mistake
and then it turns out no
it was a debate
because yeah i thought the same things
literally having me against papa plot
and i
blew my mind i swear to god he's still
cheating to this day i'll never forgive
you german man you
but uh it looks like they just did
something incredibly dumb so you just
take it yeah and then
i think you did it by accident but this
guy definitely did it on purpose it was
definitely well it was the same it was
the same thing it was a queen h5 checked
in
so it's like a queen h5 check with the
king 98 and something on e5 so it's just
the opposite one okay but it's the exact
same pattern
it's so crazy that he currently
remembers that yeah
remember well i remember that because
somebody was winning that game and they
magically started losing all their
pieces
what let's talk about this game what do
you feel about this stuff
i think i think dog is going to win the
bishop and uh tia flade is going through
the same feelings right now
imagine imagine you think you're winning
a free pawn and imagine no you're losing
a piece so
i don't know i mean we'll see if this is
not an over game though just because
the piece is gone there's there's still
going to be a lot of a lot of chances
in my experience there will be a queen
blunder at one point
if if my experience speaks of anything i
anticipate a queen blunder
um well dog we know has been working
hard
you know just like hafu so i guess it's
not that big of a surprise that he would
know an opening trap like this hikaro i
don't know i mean
it's it seems a pretty seems like he was
prepared for this idea
yeah i mean i i kind of wonder what his
training has been like because obviously
with hofu we've seen it we've i mean
we've seen her streaming a lot so we've
seen where she's getting lessons what
she's studying and so forth whereas i
feel with dog
i i know he streams some but i don't
feel like i've seen a lot of chess on
this stream right now maybe i'm crazy
it's done in the last couple of days but
i feel like in general we've seen a lot
less
so i do wonder like what his preparation
has been especially because i
i assume like he can always hear hafu in
the other room when she's when she's
doing the chess lessons so
um i feel like in some way like he's
probably
trying to do his own things it feels
like the the preparation the openings
have been different than from what
from what hoffa has done um but he's
clearly ready for this match i think the
last match when he lost his sex row came
as a big surprise
i don't think he was expecting to lose
that match um so i it looks like he's
he feels he feels more relaxed too when
i'm just looking at his demeanor he
seems more relaxed
more focused than i would say um he was
for the first match
at the end of the last game when he lost
hafu came in and i just listened to a
bit of the stream and
i feel like she she immediately was like
critiquing him like the
moment he lost his extra she was like
wow you could have done like
mama tiger's watching gotta watch
let's watch david ourselves right now do
our first listen in and see what dog dog
is
talking about i'll be okay
oh man i need to play chess
okay so what's undefended on mine my
queen is undefended but i can run
that is defended once so what's he doing
here he's attacking this
he brought out his bishop or he brought
out his bishop to attack what
nothing he just brought it out okay so
no threat
so i can push this pawn now and get
control of the center i think i like
that or i can pin it
he's probably going to castle next turn
i think i like pushing this pawn up
it instincts both are fine actually
i like getting the center pushing my
pawn up
it's fine it's fine
pretty good so far pretty good
everything's defended by one
i need to get my bishops out and i need
to start trading like i need a castle
soon
i don't know where this bishop goes yeah
so he castled so pinning is not bad
let's just push this here
and then we'll castle after it's fine
that actually sets up checkmate right
here
it's undefended but setting up checkmate
is pretty good
not like this i like this
i don't like that it's undefended it's
kind of spooky
we'll see if uh if tia blade spots the
segment but lud you said you feel like
people are taking it more serious and
then ricardo talked about
dog dogs prep i mean dog
i can tell you was one of the first
players who wanted a second anonymous
account
who contacted us so he was taking it
serious from the beginning
for sure that that is sweaty i like that
i respect that because
oh
this is bad is this question yeah this
could be this could be quick
this is going to be h7 now and then he
has to move over it's like force right
you can only go to
and if and if white sees bishop g5 to
follow that lud instead of giving the
impulsive check
bishop g5 could be lights out almost
right away
so walk through the line why is it bad
if you do what you see the reason is if
you go here first with a tempo on the
queen you
also invite a piece to this square and
if a piece fills that square to block it
or the queen even moves to safety this
is now checkmate instead of just a check
that chases the king out um i'm gonna
say something different i'm gonna say
that uh ludwig there's a reason that you
are
the uh the biggest chess streamer out
there and that's because your idea
of actually making the check first is
correct it's bishop g5 is not the best
move danny uh
what was oh because then bishop then you
get to pin the
obviously you get the king and get the
queen
of course you know thank you because
look
look obviously i don't have these these
little letters in front of my name
but obviously we see the game a little
different
you know obviously we do obviously we do
there's a grand master and international
master and the biggest
chess streamer of all time on this show
and and i am on the bottom of that totem
pole
what's up baby anyway okay yeah so queen
h8 wins bishop two five wins i think
cacarro's instincts are right this is
gonna be a short
game unfortunately yeah i the reason i
would say it's going to be a short game
as well is because when you look the
pieces for black there is no development
like the rook and the queen are on their
original square so black doesn't have
any ways to try and threaten to capture
the white pieces
but that's why i feel like there's very
little in the position for um
or uh for for tf blade
yeah it's almost like it's not just bad
it's that there really isn't even a way
for like
for dog to like mess it up right there's
not even a way for white to kind of
not not just start winning pieces
yeah i i agree yeah now i think he's
gonna see it too because if the order
makes sense to check the king and the
queen
and then what's gonna happen is check f6
and then queen takes pawn will be chuck
made i think
wow he sees hot yeah i think it's gonna
i think he's gonna play off six it's a
logical reply to stop the shock
carl's become a premonition for
predicting
the moves of pogchamps players we have a
checkmate
we're not even 10 minutes in ludwig this
is your fault you were late
no this is hey this is this is is good
there i was late and then they made the
game go quick
i i thought it says the dog dog it says
hey hurry up man hurry it up you're
gonna make me look mad
this goes to armageddon i'll look like
an idiot but did you see tf blades look
they're kind of like
okay okay i see what's going on here
okay
yeah i mean it felt like he just got
hard outplayed
like he got beat by a tactic in the
opening and then he didn't even see the
checkmate
line at all like any step of it he
didn't see the first one with the
battery
then he just walked into the mate um
right so
so that was uh that was just like a hard
out play on every street
yeah i just pressed play and took us
through the opening of that trap again
i'll do it again because
because yeah i mean this is he had to
look at this
he had to have looked at this with
somebody though there's no way i think
that he just plays this instantly
without knowing it yeah i think that's a
really cool opening
the whip out that that makes it just
like just looks cool it just looks like
you're a good chess player
right it's because it's a good opening
yeah yeah it's like
i guess that move order it is games a
lot
if they don't fall for yeah yeah i think
it looks especially good if they fall
for the trap i guess because normally if
they don't then it becomes you know like
every other chess game right what i
would say about that game is that it's
very like we have what are called hyper
modern openings where you don't push the
pawns in the center and that was like a
hyper modern kind of opening setup
very unusual and um uh
what is this opening though
who's been who's been coaching dog uh i
don't know
it's not me no i don't i don't know no
we're not gonna see the same kind of
tactic or with some e5
that would be
okay he gets e5 and if he gets d5 he's
happy so
whoever's been coaching him may have
observed that levy let me work with a
lot of people on the london which
um you know he's not levy no no i don't
think levy was coaching dog i'm saying
i think levy was maybe coaching tf blade
although maybe i'm wrong about that
she was chiu teaching i don't know
sorry i've lost track of the coaches no
i'm trying to figure out who's who's
coaching dog like tf blade i think has
had help from chihu
but dogs openings are very unusual like
they
like i would i i'm that's why i'm trying
to figure out who's coaching because the
openings are so
unusual isn't his coach a secret isn't
he the one that has a secret coach
that's like
also a hearthstone player or something
oh is it delay oh it's like zlatan
it was a secret coach and then he said
it's not delayed but we all think it's
delaying that he's just lying
ah yeah yeah yeah oh okay i'm pretty
sure he's going to see your coach yeah
yeah okay
it makes sense because i don't think he
took a lot of lessons with the coaches
that we hooked him up with at carter
like through the tournament
so i i do think like david meaning dog
dog everyone actually has
a mainline coach and all right it's
paying off this is going to be a better
game this game though
i think it's going to be a better game
than that last one do you think it's
going to be a win for tf blade you want
to go that far
i don't think it's going to be a 15 move
miniature that's what i think
i think it might be this opening is off
to a very bad start for white i think
over under 20.5 moves i'm gonna take the
under
wow especially after this last move
like this last move is very very tricky
this queen b6 this block wants to take
this pawn on b2
yeah i i mean i just i worry about this
opening it looks
this is why i'm trying to figure out who
he's working with because this is very
sharp and very to the point
it's like it's not something that's like
slow in any way i mean like
it's just very very aggressive at the
get-go it really it really is
very very yeah very very very sharp and
now bishop b4 and it's game
it's not it wouldn't be fiddler right he
said hearthstone
i don't think it's svidler it could be i
don't know
but dog dog looks very well prepared
that's what it is he looks extremely
well prepared so i'm
you know i might have to take it back
you might have a second 15 move game
yeah this is like uh this is i don't
know what happened because
i feel like you know in the game versus
zextrow
he he looks kind of like nervous and now
he just feels very confident in
everything he's doing
yeah i mean this is already game over
like
i mean how does the queen d2 is met by
met by a knight e4 but even if he
doesn't see knight e4 it's it's still
super bad for white well there's also
queen a5 oh
and queen so basically the ludwig the
reason this is losing is because you see
why i can't move the knight because
then your king is so whichever piece you
put in the way like you put the queen in
the way
black could just move the queen up to
the side of the board and you're just
going to lose this knight or you're
going to lose your queen no matter what
yeah you're it's just yeah you're
developing moves short
of a full deck you need to be able to
bring the knight out on e2
but b3 you wish you could play something
like this but since you can't it's
pretty much over this is
brutal though this yeah brutal i mean oh
he did it
yeah if black moves the queen one of
those two squares i think it's just game
over
d5 or a5 well i guess let's get a look
and listen in again we've got we've got
uh dog dog and he's
giving us his ideas we'll see if i jump
there
what do i do i'm just imagining d4 right
now if i go d4 with my knight
where does he go i don't have that much
he can take my pawn and win it with a
tactic i think i just cast don't play
normal
all right push this pawn
i gotta look for tactics here
i don't think there are any
he's just connecting his rooks and
trying to play safe all right i need to
play a move soon
that's okay but it doesn't do anything
right tuck there and there
don't check me okay
let's just uh develop the middle
everything's pretty protected right now
except for this bishop so i'm okay with
it
i just need to make sure i don't lose
the bishop to a tactic of some sort
i could even push this pawn up one more
this pawn is only defended by one this
one's defended by
well you can't jump and take it actually
because uh whatever
you guys notice he's very defensive like
it always thinking about yeah i can take
it like this actually
take it there he takes it there really
good idea doesn't work
stressed
yeah i mean i think i think he's doing
very well there's only one move for
white that's okay and it's a very hard
move to find
yeah i mean i guess it's not even okay
because a394 but still
that's a stressful thing what if i push
this pawn up
okay so he's preparing to not die here
if i push this pawn he takes i take
what happens i think i just want to
castle and play safe i'm just trying to
think of tactics right now
oh i can attack this
but then he can run away then i take
with check
so let's see if i go e4
i attack the pin piece which is huge
right
if i go e4 i attack the pin piece which
is huge
this is undefended though
then what does he do he can take this
pawn i can attack in and i probably win
the game
this isn't undefended you can take there
can you take anywhere else i don't think
so
and i can't get checked let's do it
you can pin me here it's kind of
annoying but i take
i saw that nod from hicaro you gave the
after that move he's
yeah i mean i think what i would say is
that this is the thing and i i mean i'm
sure it's something psychological
i think it's something psychological it
applies to sort of like no matter what
the game is but like
you always assume there's something
wrong it's like you're always a suit you
like even if you have the right you you
know there's something wrong with it
because
you know you're not that strong at the
game of chess but but i would say the
majority of the time
the thoughts that these players have is
fairly
it is generally on the right path or the
right track
um i remember you you heard this idea i
said on stream before
of a variation of chess where you can
see the bar
that shows you who's winning the game
like that we would
they would see what we see the analysis
bar live while playing
yeah it'd be kind of like you know when
you play a game and you have like the
scan bar and you can see your enemies
health bar you couldn't see your enemies
health bar
then you'd just be hacking away and you
don't know how long it would last but if
you know you're at an advantage so you
can become a little riskier
or whatever i think it'd make for good
it's funny you say that because it's
actually something we're working on
and it'll have its own rating system
we've talked about it called help chess
where
both players have to agree you better
get it in the email bar call it ludwig
chess
well it's gonna call help jess but i do
appreciate that
um no it'll have its own rating and i
think if people play it's almost like
just having that bird on your shoulder
makes you play better right and that's
kind of what you're saying so it'd
literally be like having a car and
actually being like nah you're good and
then you're like okay cool cool
all right or he does the well i mean you
know you know
you know what i would say ludwig on that
topic like even at the top levels
the difference it would make in terms of
a game of chess if top players had some
idea of what was going on
it would be huge because there are many
times when we play at the top level and
you're very unsure
but if we knew that the position was
winning we would automatically be able
to like figure it out
why it's winning or what's really good
we should do that we're like the type of
position changes based on
your facial expression we'll have your
face on the e-belt bar yeah right so
you'll have a happy
a happy face at the top when you're
winning and then kind of a frowny face
at the bottom
okay well i want my royalties for that
okay seriously this
this is uh someone's got to make a note
of this a lot of it chess is a good idea
for sure all right i'm making a note of
what
literally telling our ceo i'm telling my
ceo after the show
remind me to talk about ludwig chess
it's not me that it's even made it up it
feels like it's the people in a way
kind of latched onto this idea uh
what do we think about the defense here
though from tf blade
i think it's tough i think it's very
difficult
because he's going to lose this rook his
king is in check so it's a double attack
you have to move the king and then the
bishop will take the rook corner
you think taking with the queen of
smarters are just like
um he should have probably taken the
knight and give him a queen so he would
get a night in a bishop in return but i
think it's just very hard
and it's also really like this is one
thing i would say that i don't think
we've seen much of
is when someone's done so when someone's
lost a match because they've been
outclassed
it's something where they're just lost
from the get-go like you just know
they're they're not as good as their
opponent
but here i would say that while dog dog
is a much stronger player
i don't think it's like he it's like he
outclasses tf blade by the same
differential as say a match between like
austin and half thor
so i think it's there's also constantly
like he's on his back foot from move one
i think it's very unusual to see that
yeah and i think it almost seems like
the uh the difference is larger icaru
because dog dog is so well prepared that
he's like getting on the right foot and
then it gets exponentially better from
there right
the openings are paid off right yeah
yeah
would you call this a zug zong scenario
we'll call it ludswong instead of six
one let's walk
it's a song situation yeah
i mean it's just losing there's and it's
like the previous one where there's
not much of play in the position like
he's down on material but also he
doesn't have pieces in the game that's
the problem
so it's very hard to see a way he can
come back
what do you think what do you think i'm
just saying that his rating is too high
and that he hadn't played enough games
but i feel like i feel like his ratings
like it feels pretty spot-on
maybe a hundred points maybe too high at
most i feel like he's definitely all the
favorites dog dog yeah there were people
saying that he hadn't played a lot of
games on that account i guess because he
has a secret account so he's like that
account's rating is not
based off a large sample size uh but it
does feel like he's playing
like one of the best i've seen in the
tournament uh because
he also like he's also the guy right
he's the same guy who said he was going
to play slow and lose i'm playing so
that was that dog dog or is that someone
else same guy who said what
remember there was a guy who said he'd
lose by playing too slow was that dog
dog
um i believe it was him maybe i'm wrong
so there's somebody
yes it was dog yeah when levi was on
levy said that dog would rather lose on
time
yeah um but he had to get that like
winning position but lose on time or
something
rather yeah play the right moves but
yeah but because of that he
always like analyzes the board and even
really rudimentary things he's like
double checking which is like i mean
most people in this tournament aren't
doing
um right maybe four or five are
so i feel like i feel like you know what
i was giving them a lot of crap for it
last time
where he was talking about how he'd lose
on time which is still losing but
it's i think it's making him play way
better
yeah and uh part of that is the
psychology of the player there are there
are players who just
you know really are much more
perfectionist and then they don't have
it
to kick themselves to move as fast as
they should until until they have no
other choice right there
and then there are players that are
maybe just better or more natural at
you know playing quicker and there are
the other extreme sometimes players that
play too fast
right and just you know don't have a
sense of the critical moment it should
slow down right i think
um when i was a player i think i was all
three of those at one point not all of
us manage our time as well as cecaro
does naturally from the outset but
hey carter did you ever struggle with
that like like
when you were younger like playing too
fast right and then you learned look i'm
a fast calculator but i also need to
slow down a little bit right
what was what is that what would you say
no i mean look be confident and play
good moves man don't don't don't get
down to five minutes and
and be in time pressure every game just
like play the good moves quickly
and then win i don't know what you're
missing here
play fast and good and you'll win yeah
and that's the advice it's signed by tsm
which part of this isn't computing so so
ludwig
basically like danny and i go back a
long ways and one thing that you'll see
that's there's
generally there tend to be like two
sorts of schools of thought which is our
players who are moved really quickly and
players who move really slowly
and um i was very lucky because growing
up i i my stepfather who's like
2300 feed a master quite strong at chess
but he would lose a lot of games because
he thought too much
and so i saw that and that was my
example and so i'm like well i'm just
not going to
like think that long right i think danny
didn't have that and he didn't have that
kind of
he didn't have that that really really
awful example
um set first we need bad examples to
play well no i mean no but kidding i i
mean
yukari's totally right and i think that
you know sunil and hickory car you also
had your older brother right oscar was a
very strong player
right a couple years older than you you
learned from from you know
had a good a good chess upbringing you
know i was stuck in a small town in
arizona
i had to walk uphill both ways where in
arizona we're in arizona both way
northern arizona pace in arizona
yeah i know what would you play against
the local
sherpa i didn't i didn't oh yeah
imagine i would go spend summers in new
york and stay with guys like ikaru and
others you know but it was uh i see
you know it was a sob story ludwig that
is a sob story
if you were just born in the right place
hey you're you're better than a car
right now
yeah that's what i tell myself if i was
born in the right place
that's all it is baby all right well
the queen the queen blunder you
predicted eventually happened ludwig uh
although it's hard to we're not we're
not piling on tf late he's in a very
tough position
and rook d8 wins the queen it's it's
kind of getting worse here
yeah yeah i feel bad for tf blade
because again i
i think like it's when you feel like
you're really out class is one thing but
it's literally he's
in the opening like the first like three
to four moves the pressure has been on
him from the very get-go in both games
it's been very tough i think
especially when you're newer to the game
of chess like it's not one of those
things that you're used to whatsoever
it's just like
immediately at the start like there's
this instant pressure
yeah yeah this uh we've seen a minus 19
come back but i don't think that these
players
will let that happen to them what's
what's the worst comeback
you've had happen to be car or perhaps
opposite if you could well thank you
thank you for
thank you for reminding me of very bad
memories a lot of it but i there was one
time that i had a position against
magnus carlson that i think was plus 10
for me and i actually made a very bad
blunder when i got low on time and i
found a way to lose the game so
um okay well okay give us your good
story give us your good story
you came back i don't have a good story
because those things never happen often
what you've never you've had enough to
come back at one point
no he's just being one of those people
who only remembers the sad you're never
the pog
right that's how you get good ludwig
that's how you get really good is you
only remember the bad and that's like
all you remember and that gives you the
motivation
you don't remember the good why why do
you want to remember every superhero
happy every day every superhero is born
out of trouble
every day and want i think you can do
better than being happy and satisfied
better to be sad and dissatisfied but
better
or happy happy no good
happy hey i've been lowering i've been
lowering my standards for myself and
getting happier every day
so there's there's a poster child for
that okay
i saw you had a youtube thumbnail popped
up on my feed and it was your brain
exploding because you beat someone's
rank and i was like that's a happy guy
i did i i beat son and sigouria in the
like the best game i've played in a
title tuesday in a long time
and it was it was awesome i loved it
brain exploded you're a happy
yeah by the way you guys very quickly
there is one trick here there might be a
back rank checkmate if tf blade captures
this knight and
and um dog takes with the queen there is
a rookie checkmate that's the one last
thing in the position
i'm going to show it watch the email bar
yeah if you were playing a game lud and
that happened to you your opponent makes
a move
and this happens what would you do keep
it pg
keep it pg oh you know i throw on that
song
like the one where the the celebrate
good times come on and i let it play
for literally two minutes in 20 seconds
until i have one second left
then i make the move okay post it on
youtube get 500 000 views call it a day
this yeah this is just over he didn't
take the night that was the last real
hope i think once dog develops a bishop
and all these ideas on the last drink
uh evaporate i think it's just over
yep yep yep
no more back ring checkmate no more fun
pretty rough this is a weird game
because you you
i mean at least the way these people
play it is like you feel like you're
losing and you are losing and you just
keep playing
and and i i don't even know why i do it
but i do it every time i don't think
i've ever resigned
i just always go through the motions
it's very depressing in a way
you're just going through knowing what's
going to happen to you but it's
happening very slowly
right yeah it's like being beaten over
the head with like a rubber bat
like not not a metal one but a rubber
one
okay i just i just tuned in for a moment
there
my brakes are
yeah i was trying to
trying to bring a visual to your analogy
it was it was
visual it wasn't that but that wasn't
admittedly
oddly specific maybe we'll check into
government agencies but for now
uh feels like dog dog's just gonna take
it home
yeah i think i there's no way that he i
mean worst case he
draws the game but with only one bishop
for tf blade on the board there's no
chance here
yeah this is over although i feel like
it was over before 20 turns
yeah certainly um
over under you think hafu walks in
celebrates with them
and i'll throw five gifted on it okay
okay sure
sure all right i'll take that are you
taking that danny are you gonna sit down
yeah
well we'll i'll we'll throw a fine
connected from chess if she doesn't
which side are you
you're both going in i think we're both
going on in yeah all right
all right again if you're watching if
you're watching half of if you're
watching happy boost you're watching
if you want if you're watching halfway
if you're watching ludwig always already
has like i don't know
30 000 subs or whatever no no
it's 23 and right in la is so expensive
people really don't talk about it
enough
[Laughter]
i'm outside of tsm you know that's
that's true this is true we can admit
this
this is true yes this is true
oh man like i will say though i am very
happy for dog because i think certainly
that first match he
felt very demoralized because i mean he
certainly thought he was a big favorite
and then to lose the way that he did
where i thought he was actually more or
less just outclassed in that match
um it's really good to see him come back
and just play a very nice
set of games good preparation too like i
i really am curious who he's working
with
because this feels like really high
quality uh preparation
but and it's high quality high and it's
also like it seems to be well chosen
it's like he
he knows these london players are going
to play it so he knows that c5 is
exactly the thing that's just going to
destroy it right
you play c5 and move on so it's it's
it's not the opening itself it would be
brilliant against a good approach from
white but it seems to be like he's doing
his homework and it's paying off
yeah what's interesting is who will get
into winners bracket from this uh from
this group
right because zextra beat dog dog dog
dog just bit btf blade so the tf blade
zextro
game is gonna yeah be incredible that's
huge
they're gonna be playing yeah yeah i
mean i think the real question is
it really becomes interesting if cutie
beats uh beat zextra because then
isn't it everyone on one win yeah yeah
it's really fun then you have to do like
insane tie tie breakers
it's just it's not like more games right
it's usually based off some
honestly if three people are tied with
the same amount of points i
i don't remember what it is for that so
the event event team will have to get
back on that i don't remember sure
might be a little crazy pool yeah
yeah i mean i i think it's anyone's bad
i will say though if i look at the
brackets i think this is the one that's
most likely where you could have some
sort of weird
what happens if there's a four-way can
there be a four-way tie
there could be no people who have well i
guess everyone beats someone else i
think
right i guess it could i guess it
doesn't matter if it goes armageddon
it probably does right well actually
every match has the same points but yeah
yeah right but since this is right and
then
it's armageddon right yeah
but i do think this will probably be the
one of the murkiest
on on on who's gonna make it out where i
feel like every other pool
you know going in so your matches like
they don't matter
but it is pools at the end of the day so
it's like
you're you kind of are destined to end
up in winners or losers in this like
practice for
coming down to cutie and sex row next
this is going to be a big match i mean
she uh
you can do it how's that what's her
confidence level like bud uh
all-time low all-time full-time
i mean she's been practicing a lot but i
think you know it's
it's uh it's chess which is
a hard game to improve at and it's hard
to be confident in your moves and we saw
even when listening into dog dog
that dog dog wasn't confident in a lot
of the moves he played today
and he's winning like by a huge margin
and even then he's not confident what
he's doing and so i think what if we
what if we eventually had a pog champs
that was ludwig chess help chess like
we've talked about
i think that would increase the level of
play dramatically
i think we'd be looking at 1600 level
players a minimum
or you can just do it the better way
where you just have hikaru
and then he'll just he can't say any
words but he'll go
more right yeah and then you know
and then you just keep hovering over
pieces no exactly
yeah but that that is how that's how
little kids play chess when like their
first start like they moved it with the
hand
and then they like looked oh wow he
found queen b3 that was a very nice move
by dog dog
very nice chuck mate that was impressive
chia blades in good spirits yeah
yeah i mean i feel like he he knows he
just got super outplayed right like it
wasn't
you know a close game he could have won
oh i'm sorry ludwig
what she just came in oh she came in
though he's off camera i didn't see it
yeah she came in she came out she came
in she just walked
in you did yeah yeah yeah it's not on a
stream
yeah no no no no i don't see her on the
stream i don't see on the stream
here's the time is coming in it's only a
few seconds
she came and gave him a big hug she said
something then on our way out there was
there how do we know it's hafu
what if it's hafu's twin sister or
something we don't know this
[Laughter]
someone's gonna clip it i'm sure all
right all right all right well we're
gonna gift him his subs and we're also
gonna be right back as we get set for
the second matchup of the day we will
probably have some interviews everyone
with our with our last two players so
don't go anywhere more lud more hikaro
and more from this lowly i am
in just a couple minutes
says
plundered
what do you mean
so
what is this game what is this game i
think in like 20 minutes
i'm just gonna try to i don't know what
they're doing but
i have to go up once
i wasn't even paying attention so i'm
gonna lose
[Music]
so
and we are now joined by the two players
of the round we've got dog dog
david and tf blade and uh well dog dog
congratulations you feel like you you
recovered from that first matchup versus
sex row and
and found your game a little bit here in
the second match up
yeah i'm well
yeah how you feeling
dude i had no idea what was going on i
was like wait
i made one mistake and then boom
everything just like fell apart
yeah it felt like dog dog had some
really good opening strategies dog dog
who's your secret coach give us any
information have you
how much you've been working with him
tell us at least that uh
so my coach's name is ellie barath he's
like uh he's an old hearthstone player
he's like 2100 live i think but uh
yeah he's been coaching me like three
hours every day and uh
he said that whenever you bring out your
bishop like that it gets super punished
so he should just yeah and they he
showed me the lines and he told me to
review him
so three hours a day of work is more
than bug wick has ever put into anything
that's amazing all right all right all
right danny moving on moving on
do you think uh do you think there's
anything specific that's helped like
with this training that's made you
improve a lot like do you think you've
improved a lot from last game or do you
think you just played better today uh i
think i just played better today
it's like kind of nerve-wracking playing
on on
not on stream but uh in tournaments uh
i think the majority of the games are
kind of just decided by hanking pieces
so
if i can just work on that and like
focus a little bit more on that and then
maybe like
finding a tactic or two and then just
trade down i should be fine but
yeah yeah i felt you know we we listened
in
and pretty much you were just looking
for if any of your pieces were hanging
and then if you didn't see any you would
look for a tactic if you didn't see any
you'd play defensive
that was kind of your strategy and you
did find a few tactics tf played you
said that you were completely confused
by those tactics
but like well how did you feel about
this whole game were you just like lost
or were you not sure of how to attack or
what
honestly i've been only playing like one
opening and one opening only just
because i'm like wait
i haven't i don't know i'm like that
type of player that just likes to play
one thing and get
really good at it yeah but yeah so i
have no i i never played against this
tactic actually surprisingly
this was like the first time and we're
playing it live together
i was like wait this tactic being when
he pushed his pawn forward and you
thought he just was being dumb
oh no not that one actually i mean not
not this you mean the game the first
game where you were
black uh
no this game within the next three moves
and then after that i got confused like
the
rook opening the second i did that it
was basically game
over okay i've got them both
which position are we talking about here
i'm sorry so you see the rook all the
way to a1
the pawn on b2 i think i moved it to b3
yes i've never been punished for that
this was like the first stop i didn't
know
what happens after that that yeah there
we go yeah
yeah no that just yeah i
i just want to ask i was going to say
one thing like dog dog um
perhaps you have you worked on chess as
as much as some of the other
other players perhaps but i i thought it
was very impressive the way that
whether it was with your coach and and
specifically predicting what the
openings were going to be or not like
you just really
you were all over tf blade from the
start of the game from like move one
yeah um um i played one thing so it was
it was good
uh yeah shout out to my coach once again
he uh he carried me but
so he did kind of he did kind of say
that you're probably going to get this
d4 bishop before and had you prepared to
play the c5 line
he just said he always brings his bishop
out on like turn two and then he's like
so all you have to do is like attack
these squares and he's like just shove
your seep on and then yeah she'll be in
the lines
well hey it ended up working out and uh
and your guys pool is actually really
interesting because obviously only two
make it to winners two will go to a
consolation
and it's a little bit up in the air
right now because everybody has at most
one win uh at the moment i believe so
i think uh we're gonna have a couple
important games i think tf blade you
have to play
zextro still is that right yeah exactly
uh so that game's gonna be
really big for which side you want to go
on uh are you trying to go to winter's
bracket because i've
seen in the past some people like feels
like i want to
not saying that dude at this point i
don't know like there's so much high
reading that i am so i'm like
okay with either way just give it your
best hope for the best i see just play
your best chess and let it fall as it
may
yeah basically that makes sense that
makes sense well i
it was a good game for sure from both of
you yeah uh awesome
still do three hours of coaching dog dog
yeah it's uh
it's so exhausting but it's i could
imagine that's like a lot of hours
and it's like so much information it's
fun doing puzzles i love puzzles
yeah they're the best yeah true dog is
that is that something you were doing
before um the the pogchamps invitation
happened like have you been into chess
or was it this time
it was like it was it was this
tournament and then i was like
playing like you know like an hour a day
or just casually and then he messages me
and he's like hey do you want coaching i
was like yeah i think he'd be like one
coaching session
but then he's like the biggest try hard
ever and just
yeah so we're doing like three hours a
day and your coach is like making you
work on your game all the time breathing
down your neck
yeah pretty pretty much but it's it's a
good thing it's working i think a
dedicated
coach is so much uh more helpful because
then you know
like if you've coached with three
different people they have to find where
you're at every time or what you've
learned
every time carlo will you be my
dedicated coach
please watching no i don't think so
oh all right well hey boys
thank you i mean i i felt that the dog's
coach did a fantastic job of preparation
giving him good openings
uh i can't do that for you danny uh
because you're so set in your
ways with your openings that are worse
than dogs openings so
saying can't teach an old dog new tricks
something like that sure sure all right
i'll tell your coach that i might be
reaching out to him since i got turned
down but uh
anyway um we're gonna we're gonna let
you go
again uh tia blade like like lud said
you got you got a big match coming up
with sexual pretty much no matter what
happens between cutie and sexual coming
up next so
best of luck to you in that and uh thank
you thank you and david youtube best of
luck to you and your next one it's going
to be this group is going to come down
to the wire so good luck guys
thanks yeah well played good games ggs
yep
all right and our players are uh
stepping out as we get set for the next
matchup in this bracket
as you see everybody if you just tuned
in david it's not even just that he won
2-0 if there was a way to add another
point on top of that
for decisive victories like that mortal
kombat voice you know the finish him
that's kind of what he did today it was
it was brutal
yeah i got nothing else
um but i do know we're going to take a
quick break when we come back
judy's already streaming i think zextra
is also streaming
we're gonna have uh our next match up in
this group
when we return in just a couple minutes
everyone
am i supposed to play now chess
[Music]
i do need to move my horses
now you've been keeping love from me
just like you were a miser
and i'll admit i wasn't very smart four
minutes okay
and he taught me the way to win your
[Music]
heart
okay it's going well he doesn't know
what's coming from him
neither do i but it is coming it
is coming next come on we're going to
figure it out
we're going to figure it out with the
help of our
friends what is this alvin
what is this gym on christmas
wait this is important this is
alvin and the chippets
oh my god the chipmunks took on gaga
we weren't ready oh
oh my okay move our knife
who knew chipmunks were so talented do
you guys ever think
this is serious this is a serious
question
i gotta pause alvin for this i want you
guys to think for a second
okay
um
wait this is important this is important
i want you guys to think for a second
when you're driving
and you accidentally maybe run into a
chipmunk
what the [__] you guys ever think
maybe the entire chipmunks family is at
home
waiting for him
[Music]
and you're the reason
simone doesn't come home
theodore doesn't make it home all
because you were going a little too fast
have you ever thought about that
i want you guys to think
[Music]
why can't i go here
i don't know what i do now
i do this when in doubt move upon
and we're back shout out to 23 000 of
you with us on twitch and
and many more on a lot of other
platforms we got our second match up
here at pogchamps coming up
cutie versus zex row uh they're both
streaming
guys quick uh quick hiccup your quick
thoughts on what both players need to do
here
oh yeah i think i think for cutie um
probably the main
main thing she needs to do is just uh i
think be confident more than anything
else i i feel like she
you know she just sort of expects things
to go wrong she she really has this i
feel like
she just she expects something bad to
happen just because she hasn't been
improving and despite putting in a lot
of time
so i think if she's confident good
things will happen i think for sex row
mainly just doing what he did against
dog dog just just try to play good moves
and avoid making big mistakes and moving
quickly
zextrow is like shockingly confident
yeah or you know how one little time
he's put in and two new he is to chess
like compared to the rest of the field
i don't think we've seen anyone who
makes moves so brazenly and confidently
and never for a second it feels like
he's like did i do something dumb
and everybody else is like i don't know
about that even if they're better
players
and it seems to be like just helping him
one play faster and
you know do not second guess and back
out of a good move right carl gets uh
credit for that because we had a we had
we had a scheduling difficulty and a
last-minute dropout and carl reached out
right away and zextra was like yeah i'm
in um and so hikar did you know he was
into chess when you kind of
helped us bring him in at the last
second yeah i mean exactly
you invited him and now you're part of
tsm tsm collusion
it's collusion i'm telling you look at
the computer right now he has tsm
software to help him play chess better i
don't trust it
yeah i mean dexter actually like i think
he was very interested
quite a quite a while ago like uh but he
just he just
he didn't quite make the cut but he was
certainly one of those people i think
the other guy was the guy that he's been
playing a lot with calculator those are
the two guys who are on that list um
and so yeah i stepped in last minute
obviously it helped um
having certain connections with tsm for
for getting a quick answer because i
know
a lot of times when you send messages
it's very hard to tell like what what
the players um
what the players are thinking or you
know how they'll respond on social media
so what he means to say is
everybody in esports that's an
influencer is incredibly unprofessional
i'm a thousand reading in the
shockingly speech in esports everybody
talks like it's
aim it is crazy
the business deals for how much money
that get done
for the uh the amount of professionals
that are going down in twitter dms and
discord late late at night you know yeah
yeah it's like yo
and that's like the intro to like a 200
000 deal
[Laughter]
true well um we've got both players on
camera now as you can see everybody's
extra is right there
rocking the backwards hat beauty is in
her normal
i think she's in a normal streaming kind
of cave there
i think it's it's a it's a closet in my
house danny
i want to clarify it's a four by three
foot
that she streams from um
homie well hey rent's not cheap in la
and you know like i'm only at 23 000
subs so i make her pay maybe 2k rent for
that
it's a great space great space can't
beat the views
oh no she fell into a trap got a [__]
there's no way zextra doesn't see the
see the idea here
all right let's let's listen back to
work
[Music]
wait if he takes this then he's looking
at this
wait what did levy tell us to do it was
very important and it was a new thing
it was a new thing okay
levy told us levy told us to look
for attacks that they're gonna attack
and look for attacks i'm gonna attack
is that it i feel like there's something
more than
oh my i did not expect this
okay okay well he can clearly attack
this
and that's my horse so i oh oh my god
it's a fork
what a [__] oh my god
he is awful oh my god i can't believe
him
oh that is rude that's not nice
okay slow think slow
oh that's a bummer that stinker
that little bug okay well
[__] okay if we take this he takes this
we've got nothing
if i take this i can't i don't know what
i'm saying so i need to move this
because then he'll take that and then
i'll take that and then it'll suck i'll
still be really sad but it's the best
thing i can do
because if i take him with that then i
lose that anyway question mark
right wait i'm gonna lose this anyway
wait why am i losing it oh i'm losing it
to this
okay i lose it oh my god oh my god i
have this horse here duh okay take it i
guess i'll take your horse we're fine
okay bye my horse
we thought that oh my god
how is he doing this this is not
expected i should have looked
up okay know to self look up next time
look up next time
okay i specifically
you can take this he's not gonna take
that because that's backed up and he
can't do anything else so i'm gonna keep
developing my pieces
he won't expect that wait why didn't i
just go here and then if he doesn't move
i could take him
next time i'll do that next time
you can't take anything so it's fine but
i developed a piece and that's good
curious now what what will you do sir
i've moved my queen
you're afraid of women i know you are
we'll set it all down
for me you can smell my estrogen insane
analysis you're afraid
[Music]
move back up
oh unless he moves his queen here okay
we're supposed to look for checks
that's the other tip we got right now
that was my tip i have no he backed up i
knew it
okay so if i go here i shouldn't i just
i shouldn't even click
near my queen okay i lose my queen too
much don't touch the queen the whole
game
don't touch it okay i gave her two
guys here
it was fine one
don't grab a piece because she used to
do this thing where she would click a
piece
and then look where the piece could go
but she would 99 of the time
move that piece without looking at the
rest of the board right
and then two just look for some
like some attack you know because a lot
of the times in these games
you blunder something and then you feel
like you're always on the defense or
just running away and you
never ever have the chance to even like
threaten your opponent
um and so just at just look for checks
uh
and checkmates and try to find something
good
uh so yeah even if it's like cheesy or
shouldn't work
sometimes it does and it's it's worth to
either look for them so you can you can
make it happen
i like the advice you said about not
touching the piece you know hikar and
i've heard that a lot coaches would
always tell kids like sit on your hands
don't think with your hand right because
sometimes a player over the board ludwig
will
will start doing this with their hand as
if their hand is going to tell them what
to do right it's like sit on your hands
let your brain do the work and don't
touch a piece like the same thing when
you're at like target and then you open
up like the refrigerator section for
drinks
and then you're like you don't know what
you want yet but it's open and you're
like grabbing stuff
it's like it's getting cold i mean why
do you do it there's no point you're not
getting any
more information yeah
well yeah i think i think that that is a
it's a helpful thing to it's a basic
thing but it's a helpful
thing that you know since you don't play
chess from like a coach when you're 10
you don't really
learn especially with online chess right
that's the only way you're getting
exposed to it
great advice well do we want to see what
next is talking
about let's do it yeah i'd love to
i don't have this pawn protected but
it's fine
no music
waits that's it wait sweet weights no
that doesn't work
i'm so dumb for that it's okay it's okay
i didn't lose because of it
at least not yet what am i doing
wiley's sending text messages to hikaru
hey man what's your thoughts on like
moving up your night
that's what i should do
i mean i will say like a lot of what
zextra is doing
is uh is very very good so far he's
literally following the game plan that i
essentially gave him in terms of the
ideas of where to put the pieces so i'm
very impressed
you're the one who's mainly coached him
well i gave him one
i mean the thing the thing is i gave him
a lesson today but that's it i think
mainly his instructions come from
watching some of gotham chess's
10-minute videos um
so i think that's the main main thing
but he's very like
he's got this very natural kind of feel
and i i don't know but it's
i've always wondered what it is like
because certain people seem to have
a better feel for certain moves or
certain
like positions and it's not even like
game specific like we all know like
hearthstone guys they tend to be pretty
good
um or even hearthstone gals of course
because that's hawthor's main game as
well
um but like they they seem to be very
good at it but like some of these
fortnite guys they don't really
associate custom fortnite
i need to devote my pieces bro i don't
know what i'm doing is being like
similar to chess but some of these guys
and with fortnite seem to be very very
good at shots which is just it's
interesting
from a general standpoint it is weird
because i think fortnight's probably the
game that gets
dragged on the most you know for just
kids cranking 90s
right but if it translates to a game
like chess and that's that's impressive
yeah i mean yeah it makes me feel better
about what my kids are doing
say that break 90's harder kids
one day you'll be gm's
[Laughter]
yeah my kids are obsessed with fall guys
they might even watch
you both tomorrow in the uh twitch
rivals event or are you playing ludwig
i am playing that here no i'm not
playing it hikaru i am
winning it i'm feeling great about my
odds
who's your teammate oh yeah i don't
expect to win but
i have a feeling that like box blocks
and scissors
look if you just like gaze your eyes
upon my gameplay for a moment
you just see it's like i literally play
ball guys like you play chess
i will stop mid hexagon i'll look up
and then i'll just do my jumps eyes
closed
win every time you're gonna see it
tomorrow man
look hey we've made a bet today i'll do
another bet on me winning the whole
thing
did you did you deliver that did you get
them
uh you know i'll do it when he's online
you know i'm good for it i'm good for it
you know
that way people think i'm doing out of
the kindness of my heart you know what i
mean that's true
well just the rent's so expensive in la
i know you're you know so expensive
danny right
oh it is it is yeah sorry what's cutie
doing here she's
she's doing okay she she's actually
established a big center i think i think
zex
missed a bigger opportunity earlier he
almost took the knight hikaru like he
should have after
e5 i think he was holding his bishop
there and then
and then didn't and then instead went
away and now cutie's managed to hold a
decent center
so he's got a good she's got good
chances here i think objectively um
because
it's not a situation where i think the
moves are easy to play this is kind of
the thing is like sometimes when the
moves are easy to play these guys look
like absolute geniuses like today dog
dog looked like i mean he looked like he
could be a pro
player um but it kind of depends on what
the situation is and i think zacks are
struggling to come up with an idea
here yeah i think you've talked about
how the percentage is higher when your
opponent your opponent's playing worse
and you know i think judy just looked
right at the camera
and said something to us but we were
listening
here she's deep in some good thoughts
currently attacking anything he's maybe
attacking that
he's doing she's doing um
i don't freaking know i go here
i just move it i gotta develop something
it's covered with time
i just really don't seem to understand
have you guys ever had spaghettios with
the meatballs in it and again the ideas
she's having are still good
it's really chesterland
i was thinking about spaghettios the
other day and i wonder if you made your
own meatballs because i've had
spaghettios with the meatballs in it
yeah i'll trade you do i want to do this
okay this is a big choice it's a big
choice do i want to trade my queen
do i want to trade my queen do i want to
trade my queen
yes i do i do i want to do it i want to
do it
i've decided you agree with the decision
i think it's good no
not at all because she's behind yeah
mostly because i'm just afraid of his
queen
early rules is that you know queen's a
good way to come back and if you're
already down then it just makes it
harder to come back
uh at least is what i was taught
you were taught wisely who was your
teacher thanks
i'm pretty sure it was he carved for
like an hour like three months ago and
that was it
and then and then you know bowties gave
a shot at coaching me and apparently i'm
just not the most coachable person danny
so i get it
i get it some of us are just different
we learn from our own
mistakes and tribulations
you know i will say on that note
actually ludwig i thought
um out of all the players you were
probably the player who improved
improved the most without actually
taking a lot of lessons like you were
the one the players with like the self
learning i felt was was probably the
strongest
i mean there were people like charlie
who i thought improved more overall but
they were getting a lot of lessons
whereas with you it felt like it was
more like
more self self self learning or however
you're doing it
yeah i mean it's like whatever i just
like you know like an hour a day or
something
a couple of puzzles here and there
because it happens
i think i think honestly uh you know
just naturally talented
you know well that's why his biggest
chess streamer
he said it he's finally said it
i want to clip it you uncovered the tsm
conspiracy and hikaru
you're the biggest chess streamer i
watched john wick 2 so i'm all i'm all
keen to the history groups of the night
by the way about this game i'm really
unsure what's going on i i don't
know who's who's comfortable and who's
unsure here because this is getting very
very
complicated three totally and if she
sees
i thought maybe she would take here
because there was a trade opportunity
but
black is black is maybe going to win a
pawn back on d3 so if she takes her she
has
i think she's done some puzzles for
discover check because she did call it
out earlier in this game like
kind of uh you know not a discover check
but like a fossil move i guess what they
call them right
this is yeah but that is discover attack
discovered attack that's it
well i i really i feel like this is
anyone's game right now i'm very unsure
for both players like i i think there's
going to be a big blunder it's just a
question of who makes it
right yeah and i think she's a good
mindset still even though she lost like
really early
just a bad trade which can sometimes you
know make you just
throw the rest of the game away uh i
feel like she's a good mindset on good
strategies to look at
i agree and that's why she traded queens
too i don't think she feels like she's
much worse here you know i think the
advice she probably shouldn't have
traded queens but
she's feeling confident
yeah i i like i said i think it's a
question of who blunders someone's gonna
make a big blunder but considering that
cutie is behind in this game she's down
one bishop
the fact that i think it's gonna come
down to one of them making a big blunder
is very good because ordinarily you
would expect the person with the extra
bishop here to just win the game
normally right pretty sure she just
misclicked that bishop
which is because she holds the piece
that she's trying to move
again wish you wouldn't but you can't
break habits easily
right that's your advice your advice
don't touch a piece so you're ready to
move it
yeah i mean yeah i mean the best case
scenario is that you make your move
one second faster
i i you know i this is one thing that i
said and this is a direct
direct thing that i notices for whatever
reason the um the fortnite guys like
three in particular like
uh zex row scissors and nate hill
all three of them even if they're
relatively new to the game for whatever
reason they're able to
use the bishops very well um i don't
really know why but they all they all
have that ability more so than i think
some of the other players and
and it's just something i noticed that
seems to be holding true even again
today in this match
it's the vision or whatever right i
don't know maybe it's something it's
supposed to be like a sniper it's from
distance or something like that would be
comparison
but it's just odd yeah that is weird i
don't i don't know directly what any
translatable skill would be
but it is cool that there might be one
at all well she can take on c2 and now
she's down to rook
but it's there's still some awkward
things about
sex's position this rook is kind of
about the place the knight isn't ideal
yet so if she
if she took and if maybe somehow you
know that not the best moves for white
there could still be uh
things to figure out also this move 95
if you use the horse
use the horse use the horse not the
force but the horse
use the horse
okay
um yeah so she's gonna win this pawn on
d3 here um
she still can move the knight to e5 i
think
it's still very complicated
yeah i mean if she moves the bishop back
and then activates the knight
dextero has to figure out coordinating
the pieces and it's
if she puts the bishop here she could
accidentally be in a position that's
kind of like
a little tricky for white to break down
right
right agreed yeah it's i i still i feel
like there's still our chances for
both sides here i think as long as you
get yourself to an end game that's not
able to be one with like a ladder check
and
well you know two rooks or queen rock or
whatever then you have a big chance of
winning because i don't think anyone's
really confident with their end game
like if it's not a plus eight advantage
all right right that's a good point he
was looking confident there with those
dance moves let's see what she's saying
now
look at that dog behind you
valid valid response
[Music]
if i go here i die it's not worth it i'm
so far behind
[Music]
i don't know what i'm supposed to do
who are the gods what are the gods
there's like i know there's a lot but
like which ones can i pray to
aphrodite please my queen
they're like a god of chess or games i
sacrifice this maybe and i trick
there isn't there
[Music]
why didn't i do that oh no oh he didn't
see it or wait no this is fine
[Music]
whoa look at this oh whoa if she sees
the rookie wow
not fine
this is so embarrassing
i'm so awful okay i actually don't care
hmm okay this is fine we come back
we scale oh look that is cool
what i feel like she missed like that
the way she was talking
i didn't even see that until just now
wow that's crazy oh
yeah i mean like i said i had a feeling
it was anyone's game
um and it was just a matter of the
blunders and now yeah now
i still find it hard to somebody's gonna
blunder i still feel like it's anyone's
game
um but if she does not make any mistakes
she's not gonna lose the game anymore
yeah yeah i i just think this end game
is going to be insanely
weird yeah uh so i don't know what will
happen this is exactly what i was
talking about like how
how is one of the they're going to
figure out how to push their pawns
and i don't know if they have really
spent a lot of time doing that
but the fact that she saw a bishop takes
d5 a backward move of the bishop and
then
i think that kind of like opened up the
backward move ideas she immediately
found this idea to go after the spawn
like a new skill tree unlocked yeah it
was like next level you upgraded you
didn't know like oh that was an
achievement
unlocked backwards i can now do
backwards moves hell yeah
yeah i think she looks way better here
right like she has there's two pawns
next to each other
and everybody is on the right side
nicely tucked
have you and cutie talk about end games
and king action absolutely not
you know i i think she knows that the
book from
from as i say it perfectly dvoracky is
in the house
we have it i believe it's fourth edition
fifth edition i believe comes out next
month
uh you know pre-order i am on pre-order
barnes noble
but i i don't think she's cracked it
open i tried to give her
i did give her bobby fischer's book
which kind of does like
not really even end game it just does
like back ranks and like different mates
and stuff like that but she didn't look
at that one either
um i don't think she thought she would
get this far you know i think this is
like
you're not even you know what i mean
like you're not worried about end game
when your early game is is problematic
right that's true yeah this is gonna be
man i have no idea what's gonna happen i
still feel like
someone's gonna make a blunder and get
forked i just don't know who's getting
forked
okay big moment right here yeah
i'm worried that she
these are bishops under fire before
taking the pawn
this might be good for his extra two
because his king's in the fold because
it has to be
and she might not intentionally bring
her king into the fold
uh just because i want to put him in
risk
what would the king's value be if it had
one
um i feel like in the end game the
king's value is very high it's probably
worth i would say like five points in
the end game if
it can get active right um but otherwise
it's yeah basically there is no value
that i would assign to it but just in
the end game is the only time that the
king can become
actually a valuable piece yeah because
you can use it as like a piece to attack
with
but i'm going to predict this as a draw
i don't i don't honestly see how
somebody either side is going to win
here
yeah because what are you going to get
you're going to get bishop and knight or
bishop knight and pawn against the
bishop or against
they watch my video here comes the fork
well he see it knight hits the fork
i still don't think he's going to win
this though because there aren't enough
pieces on the board because the f2 pawn
hangs even if he sees it
let's see if he sees it oh he sees it oh
he sees it
i still i'm still gonna predict a draw i
don't i still predict a draw
let's see what he says now he's got a
smile back on his face
and i threw again i can't throw i can't
please don't do it please
oh my god what am i doing all right i'm
up here this is okay this is okay
i there's no way that i don't see i
don't know how
zextra can win this this is a very very
advanced someone could still get a queen
yeah i just i would be shocked if any of
them offer a draw
too which is also what makes it weird
because there's an increment
and i don't know like if they get rid of
all the pawns in the board and he
has a bishop and a knight will he be
able to find the
mate if she just gives up the knife for
the pond
this would be a great night bishop and
game video
did i do what did i do wow
i mean it's weird a car like maybe even
black has more winning chances just
because of the state of the fbn i don't
know that white will
oh he's throwing every game i know i
know no i mean no but no one could
do it no i don't think anybody could do
it um in the first pog champs or in this
pog champs um
i just i don't think it's it's possible
like even somebody like boy boy who won
their first pog champs i don't think he
could do the checkmate with bishop
knight
um so there's no way zextro can do it
literally no way
um so yeah i have no idea what's gonna i
think it's gonna be a draw though cause
that's the only result that makes sense
to me
um like i mean it's
i say it's a draw or black ones that's
my guess yeah
but i still i still lean towards the
draw because i i think unless black can
make a queen with the pawn
the f pawn there's no there's just no
way
a bit of king activation by cutie so you
haven't gone over that lud maybe she can
teach you a lesson about king activity
after this
yeah i mean she brought him in and the
thing is she was forced into battle and
i think you'd never bring the king in
unless you're forced in
and so when when she was forked
obviously you have to move the king
uh and that brought him in battle and
now he's like a real piece
and so you know i think it's interesting
to put a number
value on him because that shows how
important it is to bring the kingdom end
game like if you
you're losing a five point piece uh
which doesn't actually have a value but
you're losing that value from the king
if he's on
action no it's and i think a carl's
evaluation was right on because it's
better than a minor piece
the king is actually the only other
piece besides the queen that directly
controls every square surrounding it
which leads to a lot of very like
key tactics and key like ways to make
progress with the king
there's a juice set up right here yep
she plays at three she's i don't but she
should have taken the power
she could have just taken yeah yeah
she's taking the pawn there was a
hundred percent
there's no way she would lose i still
think there's like i think it's a draw
that's my guess i think the option's
still there and i think she might see it
right no what i'm saying is like if she
takes that pawn there's zero percent
chance she loses
it's like probably i would say like 90
draw
10 chance she wins or something but
she'll never lose if she takes this last
pawn
it's just not possible and that's an
idea that i've never considered
when i played in pogchamps is like the
draw potential and percentage and trying
to get yourself a draw
right right right so well the one thing
we haven't been talking about guys
is could be a factor and that's the
clock
he is down under a minute so somehow
well she's been hovering 50 he was
actually at two minutes though
and that's changed he's got to be
careful here because if
that pawn is going downward very fast
here you have to stop that
oh man what a good move he brought the
bishop in a car
the next move knight takes f2 was played
black could have been winning
right correct
okay he's got an idea this this is going
to be a draw though surely this isn't
the problem is how is it a draw you have
to oh
it's still a draw oh it's still a draw
even with the fork okay
the knight is the worst piece at
stopping a quarter pawn
and now and now it's now it's winning
it's a win if she sees it
but is she gonna does she know the
checkmate with a uh with the oh she
checks the other way okay
yeah she went the wrong way did she know
how to the queen against knight i'm not
sure she would not have shut down
i don't know if she does yeah god i have
no time to assume not
but i think i'm not sure
yeah this is going to be fun though okay
so really the question is as long as
cutie does not think too long and run
out of time
there's no way that she loses
oh yeah she's going towards the corner
[Music]
but you have to say overall regardless
of the result here guys this has been
this has been a very good game overall
and cutie has played extremely well
right i agree yeah well just one of the
best end games that's what i do
i go here and then i go here
i think that's the only thing i can do
yeah so as long as that's not enough i
mean i think the really question is both
players have to move quickly
oh he how do you knew oh duh i can't do
that anyway
i'm being a [__]
[Music]
the music is like making me feel like
we're about to see like a tragedy it's
like the music in like american psycho
like something awful is about to happen
here
i'm just doing time now
you're gonna lose the time buddy really
you [__]
play me come on
[Music]
let me take your bishop
okay how do i put that in check once
let's just refocus
maybe 30 seconds how do i put
how do i get here
no he's gotta move though yeah there's
too many buttons
oh you're just so you're just playing
the game you're just playing with me
i mean you're wasting time
oh you want me come over here come here
buddy oh he's in check what are you
gonna do
oh he blundered he blundered
he blunders the queen
holy [__] oh my god i'm so disappointed
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
you got it you got a place you gotta
finish this
and it's telling me he takes the knight
into draw the king has no
[Music]
oh my god i was so proud of myself
okay all i had to do was a little better
oh my god wow
well hey it is a draw and i don't know
what she at one point she was down a
pretty good amount
very swinging game yeah uh and to remind
everyone zextro
beat dog dog right zach zextra has a win
against dog dog who beat tf blade today
handedly so that's why this pool is
so [__] weird yeah yeah because
cutie could just beat zextra today and
then everybody has a win on everyone
else
right uh but yeah that's that is
like intuitively i think she could
understand that that spot was being
threatened which is why she never made
the move
but then when the queen was there just
forgot that that was like the whole
reason she could never go there
is the is because of that bishop i just
didn't look back she she played so well
i mean really no you're right
but if we're talking at the beginning of
this game the evolution of this she was
down a piece
but she was confident throughout
eventually was winning and
you know she's got to be happy with that
and uh and yeah she just
i think he car is also right that it
doesn't super matter because even if she
goes back and gets the bishop
uh i don't know if she should be able to
find him if she
played this you have 50 turns right is
that it
yep probably less because they've
already been doing all this well she's
queen at night against night she
probably would i mean
it's really just you know how to check
me with the king and queen or not like
yeah that's really the only question
that matters
but who knows but i do know she's more
confident
playing as white so let's see uh how
this opening goes
no rest for the weary game two has begun
everybody we had a draw
so uh it's gonna be fun and you're right
you said it you said it well
this group makes no sense we have no
idea who's gonna win this group right
now mm-hmm
right i agree yeah maybe people somehow
find peers
one moment i saw you were working with
him on like a king's indian
kind of pure sort of development right
well but she she was playing the
stonewall now she's bringing out both
pawns at the start
so yeah it's it's it's different she's
she's not playing the stone wall so i
know if ludwig
not ludwig sorry if levy worked with her
or um what what what she changed but
this is definitely different than
but but zex is opening you worked with
him on this no it was the stone wall the
palm is on e3 not e4
no no zekro is black now you were just
working with him on the king's indian i
saw in your stream
yeah but it was against the stonewall
set up by white the line i think he's
saying
and now it's already different all
together dc5 is not the move that i
showed him so it's already very
different
right yeah because you were giving him
that advice if it was a stonewall that
he would castle and play for knight d7
and e5 now
okay yeah you're right i'm sorry i was
just focused on his development
you are right okay he likely will just
continue the line yeah yeah
well all over the map
yeah this has been a this is a very
weird match very choppy
yeah kind of a fun one to watch yeah
wow
okay practice your king queen checkmates
right now
by the way yeah good to do
make sure you see like that that's what
i would say like that's the thing like
it's like
i i don't know to me it was weird for
example like slicker
i showed it to him one time and he got
it down like literally i showed it one
time and when when i asked him to show
me how to do the checkmate
he had it down like immediately and
certain other people like they're very
good with other pieces but they can't
make the checkmate so it's just very
it's very different when you think about
just like everyone like you would just
think it's like it's just all over the
place
for sure i think uh i think
at least having seen it helps a lot
to just be in a situation yeah it's one
of those things that's not
i don't think intuitive in any sense of
the word i don't think anyone would
naturally find that
um just jumping into it as opposed to
like maybe a ladder checkmate which just
makes sense
right okay e6 it's been funny guys
they've been staring at this tension
here
between the d and the e pawns for a very
long time probably
probably cutie could have would have
wanted to push for a long time and
actually should probably take that guy
it's like neither player knows what
their
plan okay now she plays e5 the analysis
part was jumping
yeah a lot of big chess they would have
known
look at this is very good for cutie very
good for cutie
got a great position to start
okay big center big center fall hard
yeah but knowing how to proceed from
here is a whole different question
altogether
wow what a spot great move
he's he's older a game
yeah she's playing very very well i feel
like from about like the
the later middle part of that first game
she's she's really
been playing very good moves yeah i
think it's just about trying to find a
tracker checkmate
i think a lot of the times she makes
moves hoping that it'll
work you know what i mean like i do the
same thing
they won't move this they won't protect
this right
for sure but you have to have your
opponent give you a gift which sometimes
they just don't give you and then how
you're going to win yeah
right true it should be interesting to
see what zextra does here though because
i i
i don't know what the obvious moves are
he can push the pawn and he oh yeah he
actually does it
which is pretty pretty good because
everything else is just so
losing right like everything else you
just have to accept the loss on it
yeah you basically if you don't play
that move you have to give up the rook
for the bishop yeah so you don't want to
you don't want to do that
i feel like so you keep looking right
and if cutie takes it with the pawn
she's still
in good shape um but but it was still a
nice find by zextra to block the bishop
right yeah it's going to be interesting
to see
see see what happens here
xr seems so solid yeah i mean he's very
he seems very very quiet like even when
i was giving him the lesson he was he
was very
i mean he's just a very quiet person
which is kind of interesting because
on twitter yeah yeah we all know what
happened it is
crazy what that bluebird does
that is not a good move now zextra could
push the pawn forward and he's going to
win the video
not a bad idea but her idea was she
wanted to get that bishop reopened and
so
she kind of solely focused on that but
just didn't really think about the
consequences of the
of the push but look at that zextra
didn't find it played knight c7
yeah i'm kind of wondering if with
zextro the like the quality of the play
is dropped off just because
i mean the amount of concentration
that's been required since um
since like the middle part of that first
game i think tempo has a big part to do
with it because
he could think during all of dog dogs
moves
and cutie just plays very fast and
zextra also plays fast in return
like he wondered last game because he's
just going too quickly
and so he doesn't have the time to think
and i don't know if he recognizes that
that how much extra time he had versus
dog dog right yeah i think yeah
good point no it's a good observation he
he he it's almost like zextra was more
comfortable against the
the slower opponent now yeah because he
was the faster one in that situation now
he's the slower one
uh yeah which is better and is it where
is xero if
don't mind me asking in the world is he
on the east coast
yeah he's in uh i believe he's in
virginia okay so it's not too late for
him for some reason i thought he might
have been in europe and okay he's on the
east coast got it
yeah i mean it's
yeah it's a it's whoa h4 is a great move
by by cutie i really like that move
how to play he's going full alpha zero
h4 made no sense to me why is this good
just to keep because white's going to
play white's going to push the pawn and
open up the diagonal for the bishop
towards the black king on the h7 square
carlos said yeah i just feel like
yeah that's crazy it's a very good move
whether
whether she spots the idea is a whole
separate question all the time
but it's still a very good thing to get
even
good is a good move still a good move if
you don't know the idea behind the move
can be um it can't be
it can't be like is that move still good
if you don't see the idea behind the
bishop line
uh it's probably it's just good no
matter what i see okay
and it's funny because it's even better
because
zex had just played f6 which is kind of
funny it's like
f6 weakens the light square so to get
even more advanced if she saw that idea
this is even stronger precisely because
of zextra's last move which is why we
were both kind of
oh wow it looks like it looks like a
response in an
actual game when it might have just been
hey from both ends
right this point
yeah this is um this is looking very
very good for for cutie she just has to
find a couple of critical moves in
attack here and not be
sort of more passive i i get the sense
in general she wants to be aggressive
with the way she plays but she hasn't
really been in the situation where she
can be very grumpy
dog's lonely
a kitty it's a little kitty low junior
it's a kitty or a dog
i'll show you my cat
my cat elderweight jr gonna meow in a
few seconds
your cat looks like the bad guy in an
anime movie
like let me see the face you're watching
we're watching fur beasts or whatever
that one is what do you want b
stars over there what are you watching
danny what are you watching alright come
clean come clean
oh man look at this new g3 look at the
pawn structure hikaru look at this this
yeah this is um yeah very complicated
game
a lot there's a lot of like uh tension
in the center of the board
with all these pawns so some i still
expect i think this game is gonna be
i don't even know how to judge it but
somebody's gonna make a big mistake
it's just a question of when and that
that is a big mistake whether cutie sees
the reason it's a mistake
i think it's unclear but but she has
played this game very well so far i will
say that the game has been very very
impressive
why are we listening to cutie we haven't
heard her thoughts on this game yet see
how she's handling thoughts about the
pawn structure here
because that opens me up to this or
if i don't take this piece he takes me
next
yeah i'm gonna take this piece because i
already have two on this file anyway
i i i think i feel like i'm not thinking
this through
which is bad sign but i also i'm getting
so impatient because i'm just so
[__] bored i just like don't know
okay no stop you have time count
okay ready one wait wrong way
one two
not three because of that guy
sure what i don't [__] care just go
just like i can't keep sitting here i
can't do it
okay i can't go there that's fine it's a
trade but it's fine because i'm
up okay now what
can i start doing something can i take
this or something
and then he takes me nothing is
happening i'm losing my mind
and then what happens what do i do after
that
[Music]
no because i don't want stacked pawns
i move this up one while i think great
that's crazy so let me move this horse
somewhere here
[Music]
yeah because you don't like you know
what i mean i just don't know what to do
here yes
right maybe five heads
[Music]
so if i take this let's count one
it's just a trade that puts them in the
same spot
i can go here for free this is a free
spot
right
this is a free spot i go
that's a good one not very good sure
fine i moved like a big hat the big
question is that's true move his knight
and open the line for that file for the
rook that's the big question
um and i i don't actually know whether
he'll see it if he sees that i think
it's very much a game but whether he
sees the idea to move the knight and
attack the bishop is unclear
that move she did was like a cat when it
finds a cardboard box and just jumps in
it because it's open
right we'll call this the cap the box
yeah it fits
if i fit along with the wooden shield
right there uh but yeah i think that she
does bring up a good point where chess
uh and i think a lot of high level games
it happens in valorem too where you're
setting up for so long
and the point of action is so short that
it can feel
boring because like most of it is like
it's like just pre-production you're not
actually doing the fun part for the
quote-unquote fun part until very late
because you want to make sure you can
succeed at it right
like it's the same with everything like
same with making movies like production
is usually longer than the actual
filming
or you know in valorant they do spend a
minute and 20 jumping around sites
before they actually explode on the site
and someone dies
uh because you don't want to give your
opponent anything early that just
makes it over too fast right
that makes sense yeah i think i think
you're right that's the hardest thing is
saying like calm and just like just
trying to still just play normal moves
when you're getting bored
very difficult
replace knight b3 now we've we'll see if
she starts to realize
her space advantage here because one of
the big things she has is
the further advanced structure so if she
starts to kind of recognize that and
infiltrate a little bit
okay if it's not a bad move either if
she can if she can bring pieces to the
square here
yeah right
yeah i mean i it's i just feel like
they were this is going to be like this
big build-up and there's gonna be one
huge blunder someone's gonna hang a
queen
or hang a rook and the whole thing's
gonna collapse yeah um
like because there's just too many
pieces on the board and it's too closed
all the pawns like the king slide all
the pawns are closed
um so somebody i think is just going to
get low on time and make some sort of
really big mistake
i just don't know who it's going to be
bill's very much like the first game the
players feel very evenly matched here
it's funny because of the two matches i
don't know why i thought that this one
had two of the
less experienced players the first the
first match was over so quickly but
these two feel like
i don't know they're playing some of the
best chess i've seen beauty for sure
cutie definitely is playing a lot better
than she did in the first match
100 i i totally agree
good move backed up to safety
very good yeah i would say again as i
think back to her match against tf blade
i think she was doing okay even in that
match and then at one moment she just
blundered her queen
and that's really the critical thing is
that she um that she tries to avoid that
happening
here
she is winning on the board she's got a
much better position
now that's a very bad move but the
reason it's a very bad move to me
seems very unlikely to be yeah that
seemed like a great move to me because
there's no way to immediately defend it
and now it's stressful now there's a
queen
that's right it's like right here like
the yeah it's like that's threatening
yeah it's throwing a bunch of stuff but
i guess the queen's blocked in is that
the idea or something like that
i think the idea is that white here can
um white can catch this pawn on b6 for
starters
uh that's that's just a free pawn to be
captured and everything how are you
gonna leave a queen in your home
though well that's what that's what
that's why i'm saying like i would be
very scared here because it's just
unless you like if you have a lot of
experience you can see there's nothing
under attack but yeah it feels like the
queen there's something
something you're you're going to lose
something yeah if you actually do the
math
nothing there is no problem here and
this queen is almost trapped so taking
here
is a great move but you're right lut
it's probably more likely you panic when
you see this at this level yeah
i don't i do not let troops quarter at
my homes during times of peace it's my
what's my what amendment is that fourth
i exercised that right
so i would i would excavate her from my
home
excavate you mean evict right hmm
you don't excavate someone from your
home excavating well who's the english
major here hikaru is it me
or is it you i got a degree for it so
i'm pretty sure
it's excavate
accident that's not what excavate means
what are you talking about excuse me
sorry excavate means
when you go to college for english you
learn what's called english too
and that means we get to unlock new uses
for words
and i just thought that you guys were on
that level but if we're not all there
i'll back it up a bit i'll back it up
[Laughter]
oh my gosh oh she does do the move
eternity
yeah very good and now i'm gonna put i'm
gonna be make a bold statement here i
think cutie's gonna win this game
because i think that pawn
is gonna be such a such a thorn for
zextra to deal with
i know this could still be anybody's
blunder but just something about that
pawn i think it's going to is going to
survive a lot of problems and that's
going to be a uh
that's going to be a winner for white
yeah that sounds like the most useless
pawn to me but that's crazy that that's
that's the analysis of how useful you
think it is
because it seems like it's just like you
know it can die at any second
but if she if she sees it for what it is
night day five is
is a fantastic move here but even if she
moves the night anywhere and just holds
onto the pawn
i i think that it'll it'll show she kind
of realizes her advantage here
i think 95 is a very hard move to play
here uh
immediate i think she's been all day
today
looking at what the rooksy's past the
pieces
you did in almost the opening of the
game game one
uh where she's just concerned about what
the rook can see if you move out of the
way like that discovery
uh and so i think that's fantastic that
was a really good point
i still think there's some danger here
but she she is playing extremely well
now
yeah the best for sure she's played
and better than game one really maybe
from start to finish this is
oh a hundred percent yeah totally better
i mean it's kind of like uh
i don't know openings with queens this
is what it feels like it feels like the
queen's doing all the work here like the
queen's made so many moves in a row
you could just lose a game so quickly if
you just mess up one thing it feels like
as white here you just mess up one thing
and then the queen just eats everything
in a row
yeah i mean that's why i'm saying like
even though i think cutie is probably
much better it's still hanging on his
like yeah oh my gosh are we gonna get a
drunk magic oh my gosh
it doesn't go to armageddon does it it
does it does really
yeah but she's winning if she sees she
has b7 but she's
she's maulding right now when zextra
brought the queen back
you freaked out let oh she she fell okay
let's go check on her
come on i'm dying here
oh good job you did it finally jesus
christ
okay thank you finally we're doing
something
okay his queen is attacking nothing
great
perfect finally i just want to like play
i just want to move some pieces even
though that would just be a suicide
i just want to do something cool why why
is this game just like
freaking so dumb it's so dumb
it's just like you just tiptoe around
the freaking
tulips the whole entire day it drives me
crazy why are we doing this okay
i'll have a word with her man i don't
know i don't know you know
she doesn't know charlie
oh i just gave up that i gave him that
cause i'm so [__] bored of sitting
here
i'm so bored of sitting here i don't
care everything's in the way
god damn it that's gonna die or this is
gonna die
i just i can't even sit still anymore
this has been the longest game i'm gonna
lose it i had a fine setup but i'm so
[__] bored of sitting here because
nothing has been going on i'm losing my
mind
okay breathe we have a minute
yeah maybe i should get recaro to teach
me how to just move a piece back and
forth in the same spot
over and over again and be a goddamn
[__] i'm so bored
[Music]
it's funny because she says all this but
you could tell she really do i don't
even know what to do
because i'm just i just i haven't even
been paying attention i just i don't
know how you do this
i don't know how you sit through this
sure go i'm just gonna go here
i just even gonna go somewhere i'm just
gonna go somewhere
you come here i take you do it please
please just do it
please just trade something you're up
pieces just take my piece
but that's not the one i wanted you to
take but that's fine
bud you're going to tell us that it's
fun we took some pieces
yeah look that was fun okay talk with
her and the conversation is going to be
hey look i get it i feel you
but you play league of legends in your
spare time so it's like come on this is
not that far
gone from the game of league all right
the game of league is not like the most
action-packed
you kill cpus for 99 of the game
true
but i do understand that feeling
uh and i don't think this game is too
far gone yet no definitely not i still
think she has good chances
and then she could have two pass pawns
which which could be really hard to stop
well my concern is that she's gonna
trade like my concern is right she's
gonna take a bishop here
and then the rook will take and that
she'll continue to
trade down when she's already down an
entire rook
uh which is just not good
yeah because the alternative is playing
slower
which is like i think we all understand
is not what she wants
right but there's also another there's
also another problem i realized which is
the knight looks really good
but she needs to bring the knight around
it's actually not doing anything on the
square it's on
and trying to bring the knife back is
just not natural at all
the cat's in the box the cat needs to
get out of the box
if sex removes the bishop and then
doubles up the rooks on the on this
on the a file i think he's probably
gonna win
but both players don't have a lot of
time anything can happen
yeah i think time will definitely play a
factor in this one
on who gets it yeah he's offering the
trade so this is kind of smart of him
understanding that she's just trading
down she just wants to she wants the
action
yeah she just wants the smoke so any
offer he gives her
he's kind of a hungry boxer in a way
like he kind of just
camped her out a bit until she got so
bored that
she just threw away and then just
offered trades because
you know she's gonna take him
he would like hungry hippos remember
that game hungry hungry hippos
non-stop action non-stop actually it is
non-stop that is the fun thing about it
okay come on cutie see rook b1 that's
our
it's the last chance i think i think
rookie one is a better move actually
okay yeah she still has chances all
right this isn't bad either she's trying
to get the knight out of the box at
least
yeah because this will bring the knight
around
by sheer force yeah i guess what i would
say is if zaxar doesn't blunder
something he's going to win the game
but the odds of the blunder by either
player are really high still
don't trade that's a good move too
offering a truck yeah yeah classic
don't trade cutie oh good okay
now he's got that fight now yeah that is
hype
and he might just be staring at this
rook
he's he's trying to play one look
adventure yeah i had a feeling you might
see that blonde hair i was actually
thinking
backward bishop moves that was the level
she unlocked will it be seen yeah she
didn't want to see
the next level backward bishop didn't
unlock at this game she unlocked it last
game
right does zextra even realize that he
doesn't
i don't think he does he's hovering over
it like he's about to make another oh my
god
now he does i just need to quit playing
bro
i don't know if she sees it yet though i
could still win i could still win
bro every time i just stop thinking when
the clock goes
chess has brought them to a dark place
he's not seeing it she didn't see it
oh my what a shame
i think it's only because it was forced
to her and then
she was looking at it as opposed to now
especially mentally where
she feels because we've already seen one
rook blunder oh
um
yeah now i think it's very hard if if
zextra moves quickly and doesn't get low
on
doesn't lose on the clock i think i
think this is over unfortunately
yeah i hope she keeps all of her
remaining pieces alive
even though there's not a huge idea with
them just for the
reason of winning on a clock because
there's no
clear attack yet for black
so it's not like you can figure it out
in 55 seconds
yeah no i totally agree i think at this
point both players need they just have
to make moves
yeah that's really the thing and she's
clearly shown the desire to do that
pretty early right yeah what i would say
is zextra has played a lot of blitz
chess though where he's played with like
five minutes or three minutes on the
clock so i think he is a little bit more
familiar with this perhaps
um rook c7 is a good move that was good
and it's making him think he's chewing
away at his clock
huh he's going for this he's going for
the checkmate
double the rooks i think guys got the
rook down
and he's i think he's got he's he has a
force checkmate
look down on the rook now look down
and even if the king goes here the rook
comes back door and it's still going to
be made
exactly yeah i wonder if we'll see it
because it's a back door in a weird spot
i don't know if you'd immediately notice
that
because you always assume backdoor has
to be on their original line
right that's yeah look at the time still
i mean this is this is going to come
down to a time scramble
yeah i agree yeah i think for sure
now if she brought out her bishop that'd
be hype even though
now he's meeting two oh now he can just
make the checkpoint
yep now he could now he could fall into
the ladder checkmate just by
accidentally checking
but he's gotta move he's got him down oh
he sees
it he's it
oh no yeah the ladder
that's and he does it
gg's a win for zextro uh
an up and down game with actually not
that much action at the end it felt like
you know it felt like they were building
up to this moment
and it kept it came a couple times but
wasn't you know
capitalized on and honestly uh
you know crazy it was a crazy game it
was a crazy game uh but that zextra win
means he's leading the pool i think
right now
yeah both matches yeah yeah so that's
that's pretty big for him it'll be a
weird toss-up for dog dog and tf play to
see who will be the last to get in
well we have uh well tf blade and zextro
play
yeah definitely won his match normally
right against cutie
yep yeah he had played wins if tf played
wins and zexter doesn't make it
yeah so it's it's going to be a really
weird toss-up between the three of them
uh and we'll see what that happens with
that later this week i'm sure
all right we'll have uh final thoughts
about the games the players and
everything else another another crazy up
and down
affair that was podcamps don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
so
and welcome in um judy
you played so well today you were
winning in this position as white did
you realize it
i realized that i was winning i just
just i just didn't know what to do when
we were just sitting there
do you have any words for zextra what do
you mean when you were sitting there you
guys were playing chess
you're a damn [__] [__] i'll say it
wow
nothing you were doing nothing i was
losing my mind what was i supposed to do
i i did do something i pushed up the
right side i'm the one that initiated
everything
uh i think specifically what brought her
to the point of of boiling over was when
you moved your queen
yeah right here you had it yeah yeah
yeah on the right side and then you just
moved it
you think that's funny i don't think
it's funny i didn't know what to do
i had to play aggressive how to make i
think you know i didn't know what to do
either
i don't know what to do do i throw a
piece and then i start eating pieces i
don't know what to do
i was losing my mind i don't know how to
sit still zextro did you
feel like you knew what you were doing
did you feel confident at all
when i when i pushed the queen up yeah i
like thought of everything
no in general this game oh yeah well
did you feel like you had an attack a
plan of attack or general that it was
kind of locked up and you didn't really
know how to enter
uh no i mean i knew what we were doing
we were both like
just holding everything but then i saw
like an opening on the right side you
know so i just went for that
i see i saw no openings
uh yeah i mean there weren't any really
obvious openings
uh like blunders given to either player
um
until the end and then there were and
then you didn't see them either but
i mean i saw some of them i saw some of
them and i just did that because i
wanted something to happen
i needed something exciting to happen in
my life nothing exciting ever happened
in my life come on
let's talk about game one because game
one is interesting because x-ray you
were up in a pretty big way
and then uh cutie brought it back and
then the end game was crazy it's
probably the closest
end game that's ever been created in
pogba ever been recorded on pogchamps
right here cutie gets the queen
after all the hard work and then oh this
was so sad
and then blunder the queen cutie do you
think you would know do you know how to
do a queen king checkmate
yeah i do the latter i know the latter
well so now alicia taught me the latter
the ladders is good and i think it's
it's what uh
zextra did game two but no not ladder i
know what you do i know how to do it
don't
freaking mansplain to me right now i
know what to do i go with my queen and i
do an l
shape and then i slowly get him into the
corner and then i move my king and then
i check mate
that's fantastic that is it so you
understand we weren't sure
if you had known how because i never
knew you'd never like i don't know i
have done it
i've done it on all the i've played
chess i thought
you played chess i'm just saying we
weren't sure i don't practice i do
i knew how to pull it out i just
happened to give my queen away for free
you were close to winning game one then
very very close
yeah you were super close and and you
did you you played
very well overall in both games the
reason i brought up this position is
because
i know i know it was boring and there
was a lot of you know oops a lot of
close stuff that
happened ruined my uh my screen
nevermind fixed it
a lot of close stuff that happened here
but i don't know
at some point we were wondering if you
would realize your advantage of the
b-pawn
was almost one move away from just
winning a ton of material here
did you did you were you looking at the
rook and the b-pawn here or did that
just
wow yeah i could have done something
there huh
that would have been cool that would
have been very cool
it's like you did all the work and set
all the foundation
and then you're just like ah [__] this
and then you walked away but you like
you did all the work the hard work to
get to the fun part
and then you just ditch at the fun part
it's like the meme of the guy
who's digging for diamonds and then he
gives up at the last sliver
you know what i mean he could have just
kept digging for diamonds
yeah yeah and you can see that was
his ex wow did you realize how dangerous
this position
was for you with the b-pawn or you you
were you were feeling comfortable uh
uh right there uh yeah i was feeling
calm i don't remember what i was
thinking about
i think i was i thought of something
some way to trade it but i don't
remember
at one point you almost blundered your
rook but you didn't see it
uh which would have brought the game
back to a tie because she blunted her
rook you took exactly yeah
and then you uh you know just
went around for a bit you were offering
trades which was kind of smart of you
because she was
it felt like down to trade anything oh
yeah right there oh bro
i i've never played that bad uh oh
that would have been cool yeah right
here you would have you would have uh
been super super winning that's about
when i got very
i was very mauled yeah what happened is
you you you got mauled you blundered and
then
zextro i don't know if you intentionally
did this but you just offered a trade on
everything
and then cutie you took it all and
there's like a general rule in chess
where you don't trade if you're down
because then you just have less pieces
to come back with like if she's up one
pawn and you trade everything then he
just has two pawns to your one and then
you just lose
but like we had played one game and now
we are on our second game and that is a
long time to play chess
it is that is a lot of games yeah i
think hikaru might be maulding over here
after playing you know
300 games in a day or however many he
plays but two can definitely be draining
in tournament especially i gotta throw
an idea at you because we were talking
during the broadcast about
what if you could play and and you could
see
this happen not the move but if the eval
bar did that while you were playing it
was almost like a bird is on your
shoulder maybe like a mini ludwig
is telling you it's like a little mini
ludwig saying hey guess what you're
winning
now if you find the move right which was
yeah that would be fun or like a little
game of pac-man if i could play like
snake on my phone in between
okay this just feels like maybe maybe uh
the drug adderall would help
for what you're concerned about oh my i
might get cheetos i actually have
decided next game i'm bringing
cheetos so then when i'm bored i can
have cheetos
if there was like a help chest if there
were if do do you really
if the confidence was there cuties i
mean jokes aside i was
that actually is maybe a game we would
invent where you could play with the
eval bar
but do you feel like sometimes if you
had the confidence to know you were
better
you would have found the move but it's
that you you're just you just weren't
confident in your position already
i knew i was winning i just didn't know
how to win got it
and then i just got so bored that i
didn't think about it i would help zex
too for knowing when he's in trouble i
feel like zach sometimes is in trouble
and he just thinks everything's fine
after it's done he's like oh it worked
out uh i will say zach's at the end you
said you felt like you didn't deserve to
win it why did you say that
um lots of bad plays there i saw
so many ways i could lose at one point
it was crazy just the general execs
even with that being the case you
realize you're leading your bracket
right now
oh yeah that that's for you that's the
wildest part
yeah there's a chance you make it into
winners it's going to be a crazy race
between utf blade and dog dog i think
every game matters even if you lose
winning one and getting to armageddon
will change who makes it to the end
uh because you beat dog dog and
obviously dog dog beat tf blade today
wait so how does that work it'll it'll
come down to how many games you guys win
uh it'll come down to mainly your game
vs tf blade
uh and then dog dogs game with cutie but
all the games will matter
uh and you know it's still up in the air
but you are the
most poised right now because you have
won
two of your games of the three okay okay
so we'll see it'll probably end up being
somewhere maybe a two win tie
or if you win you're easily making it
through we'll see we'll see what happens
with the rest of group c cutie you are a
hundred percent going to the consolation
bracket which
i don't think is a bad thing that's been
my goal my coach can vouch
i told him from day one i want to go to
loser's bracket because that's where my
friends are and i want to hang out with
my friends it's like going to hell or
going to heaven i don't want to go to
heaven none of my friends are there i
got to go to house
you know who's dumber than me my friends
i can beat all my friends at chess
yeah well i think austin xuc and carson
are pretty much guaranteed
conor will probably end up joining them
i'm taking all of them down
you will have a bunch of friends down
there i would put you as a dark horse to
uh to win the consolation cutie
really yeah i am the dark horse to win
the consolation bracket i've told
everybody i've told my family already i
called them and i told them
raising of you i will say because you
will have one of these people in this
group with you possibly xexro
or if he makes it on tf blade or dog dog
we'll see what
doesn't understand what happens when i
have cheetos when i have cheetos it's a
whole different game
that is a new game we will make ludwig
chess daniel and then we also need
cuties
where everyone's cheetos got it everyone
sent cheetos
this could be a great brand activation
i'm sure we'll make millions on it
i'm looking for a cheetos if you guys do
one sponsor
those videos where you eat every flavor
of cheetos you might get it i mean
i've seen the oreo videos and then you
just
grab the pieces and then the white
pieces become the orange pieces that'd
be fun if i'm on the white side i can
eat normal cheetos
on the black side you can eat hot
cheetos
about this idea offline every game sure
i think the car was about to fall asleep
and uh zex probably has somewhere to go
i'm kidding this has been a lot of fun
though seriously the games were good
today
um cutie we know you're going to the
consolation but you know you played
super well like you said it was your
plan anyway
and zex uh dude last minute but it's
awesome i mean
you're playing so well here in the
tournament i can't wait to see what
happens here
and and maybe you'll move on to the
championship bracket
yeah maybe today today wasn't my best
though but uh
i mean i was up like plus 12 at one
point and then lost that so
what's been practicing uh yeah hikaru
taught me
a couple stuff earlier practice more
just keep being a [__] and you'll do
great
all right thank you boys for watching
hey let's take a look at the groups here
daniel what do we got
uh we're gonna say goodbye to our
players here thank you both and good
luck
um and then we're gonna talk about our
groups and wrap up hybrid
bye bye cutie bye zach thank you guys
goodbye
well that was an interview we will say
that um
and uh there's our groups there's our
groups right there
uh yeah your thoughts yeah i mean i
think most of the groups are pretty much
uh clear-cut really i think the only
only two groups there
where there's potentially a lot of drama
which i would say it's group c and group
b
um xuc comes up with the performance of
his life and beats hafu there could be a
massive tie potentially
for second place in that bracket um and
then group c
of course zector against tf blade can be
a very uh very interesting match
as well so i think b and c is where
we're going to see the most interesting
and calling final round matchups a and
eight groups a and d i think
it's pretty certain who's going to
qualify at this point but again
there's there we play the game to see uh
see who will qualify
into the winner's bracket constellations
it's fun
all right well um we'll uh
say goodbye to our groups and and say
goodbye to each other for a day we we
officially
have a rest day tomorrow let all the
fans know now uh the schedule that we
had out the twitch rivals event came out
and it seems that so many of our players
and our our hosts here are actually in
the event so it kind of made sense for
us to
take a day off for all the pogchamps
fans peace please pay close attention we
will announce as we uh reschedule
matches
that were originally supposed to be for
tomorrow so um
again the day's wrapping up congrats
again to tsm hikaru
do i start calling you that do i have to
start saying that or can i just still
call you nicaragua
is it tsm gm or gm tsm
i don't know do you think they want a
tia do you think they're into a
car are they looking for a tsm i am huh
yeah are they looking for a tsm i am
uh yeah or do they wanna you know tsm5
head
like i am currently labeled do you know
me five head of chess
we'll figure it out all right he'll hold
us in i'm sure will be the new blood of
the tsm but thank you boy it's been a
pleasure commentating for you today
likewise guys all right well on behalf
of everyone here at chess.com the crew
working hard
all of our players my co-host here thank
you to everyone who tuned in
we will not see you tomorrow go watch
hikaro and bloodwig playing some fall
guys twitch rivals we will see you back
for pog champs on saturday august 29th
and until then take care everybody and
we'll see you later
i don't know what to do
queen d one doesn't work because i mean
it's checkmate but he doesn't have to
take it
do
the queen is hanging which i don't like
so